ओके आई थिंक आई एम लाइव
आई थिंक आई एम लाइव राइट सो गाइस ओके लेट
मी नो गाइस
ओके आई एम लाइव लेट मी चेक
ओके गाइस सो आई एम लाइव नाउ एंड आई थिंक
यू कैन सी एंड प्लीज लेट मी नो इफ इफ माय
ऑडियो एंड वीडियो इज गुड प्लीज प्लीज
प्लीज लेट मी नो गाइज़ फास्ट हरी अप प्लीज
हरी अप एंड लेट मी नो जल्दी से बता दीजिए
कि मेरी ऑडियो वीडियो बिल्कुल सही आ रही
है आप लोगों को बिल्कुल परफेक्टली आ रही
है जल्दी से बताइए फटाफट बताइए हेलो
एवरीवन यस एवरीबडी प्लीज
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके ऑल गुड ग्रेट ग्रेट
ओके [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
चलिए ऑल ओके है। सो
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़] लेट्स बिगिन द
क्लास 33 अ
ऑफ
दिस एसओसी
एल वन फ्री जॉब रेडी ट्रेनिंग अ बाय
डिफ्रॉनिक्स आज 33 बेसिकली हमारा क्लास है
एंड हम बहुत ही क्लोज जा रहे हैं इस सीरीज
के खत्म होने के एंड काफी इंटरेस्टिंग अभी
होने वाला है आने वाले सेशंस जो होंगे आज
के जो सेशंस हैं काफी चीजें अभी आपको
जानने को सीखने को मिलने वाली है अपकमिंग
सेशंस में। सो [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
अभी तक जो भी लोग यहां पे जॉइ हो रहे हैं,
आई होप आई अस्यूम कि आप सभी लोग ने
स्टार्टिंग से सीरीज को फॉलो करा है मोस्ट
प्रोबेब्ली एंड अभी तक आप जुड़े हैं। सो
से कांग्रेचुलेशंस टू योरसेल्फ। अपने आप
को आप धन्यवाद एंड थैंक यू भी बोल सकते
हैं। कांग्रेचुलेट कर सकते हैं कि आपने
इतने टाइम तक इस सीरीज को फॉलो करा है।
एंड यू हैव स्टिक्ड टू दिस पर्टिकुलर
सीरीज। बिकॉज़ अगर आप किसी चीज से स्टिक हो
के कोई चीजों को सीरियसली करते हैं तो
डेफिनेटली उसका एक रिजल्ट अच्छा आपको
मिलता है। एंड ये रिजल्ट आपको मिलेगा इस
सीरीज को फॉलो करके। मैं आपको गारंटी इस
बात की देता हूं। ठीक है? सो बिफोर वी
बिगिन मेरे पास एक चीज है जो मैं आपको
दिखाना चाहता हूं। सबसे पहले आप हमारी
डिफ्रॉनिक्स सर्च कर लीजिएगा। YouTube
चैनल पे डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी और जो है हमारा
YouTube चैनल जो है ओपन कर लीजिएगा। ठीक
है? जैसे ही आप ओपन करेंगे यहां वीडियो
सेक्शन में जाइएगा। वीडियो सेक्शन में
सबसे पहला चीज मैं आपको पहले बताऊंगा। तो
हमने यहां पे एक एथिकल हैकलिंग की फुल
कोर्स बिगिनर टू प्रो लेवल वन शॉर्ट
वीडियो कोर्स जो कि लगभग 5 घंटे की है ये
हमने आपके लिए ला दी है और यह भी पार्ट वन
है। यस यू हॉर्ड इट राइट दिस इज़ जस्ट
पार्ट वन पार्ट टू इससे ज्यादा एडवांस और
इससे ज्यादा इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक्स उसमें
होने वाले हैं। एंड एथिकल हैकिंग जो
बिल्कुल ही अफोर्ड नहीं कर सकते किसी
ट्रेनिंग कोर्स। इवन ₹500 के भी कोर्स
अफोर्ड नहीं कर सकते या ₹1000 की नहीं कर
सकते। एंड उनको एक क्वालिटी कंटेंट चाहिए
था स्ट्रक्चर वे में। वो इस वीडियो को
जरूर देखेंगे। एंड इस वीडियो को जब आप ओपन
करेंगे बेसिकली तो आप इसको इसको बहुत ही
डिटेल में ये वीडियो बनाई गई है। तो 5
घंटे की है। प्लीज इस वीडियो को जरूर
देखिएगा। डिस्क्रिप्शन को एक्सपेंड करके
आपको WhatsApp का एक ग्रुप मिलेगा इस
WhatsApp ग्रुप को। इस डिस्क्रिप्शन में
या तो पिन कमेंट में पहला जो कमेंट होगा
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
WhatsApp का ग्रुप होगा। इसको जरूर ज्वाइन
कीजिएगा। जहां पे हम आपको फ्री सपोर्ट भी
प्रोवाइड कर रहे हैं। यानी आपकी कोई डाउट,
कोई क्वेरीज हो तो वहां पे ग्रुप में आप
पूछ सकते हैं। आपके आंसर मिल जाएंगे। यहां
एक टाइम स्टैंप दिया हुआ है। और दूसरी चीज
आप जब मोबाइल से इस वीडियो को देख रहे
होंगे तो वहां पे एक हाइप का ऑप्शन आएगा।
हाइप कर दीजिएगा। जितने ज्यादा आप हाइप
करेंगे YouTube उतनी ज्यादा वीडियोस को
रिकमेंड करता है। और इसको शेयर कर
दीजिएगा। क्योंकि जैसे ही इस वीडियो पे 3
लै व्यूज हो जाएंगे। इसकी पार्ट टू हम
लेकर आएंगे जो कि बहुत ज्यादा मतलब ऐसे
कोई लेकर आया नहीं होगा पूरे YouTube पे।
मैं इस बात की आपको गारंटी देता हूं कि जो
पार्ट वन और पार्ट टू को देख लेगा।
YouTube पे वैसे आर्टिकल कोर्स किसी ने भी
नहीं डिलीवर करा होगा। आज तक का मैं अभी
तक का प्रेजेंट का आपको डाटा बता रहा हूं।
तो प्लीज पार्ट टू जब आए जल्दी आए इसमें
आपका ही रोल है। जस्ट यू हैव टू गो एंड
शेयर द वीडियो। जैसे ही 3 लाख व्यूज आएंगे
एंड इट विल कम फॉर यू। पार्ट टू आ जाएगा।
अभी 26,000 व्यू हो गए हैं मात्र 10 दिनों
के अंदर। एंड इट इज अमेजिंग। सो, यह सब
आपके कारण हुआ है। एंड आपके कारण ही फिर
वह 3 लाख भी होंगे। तो, जल्दी जाओ इसको
शेयर आप कर दो एंड देखो इस वीडियो को
देखना जरूर। उसके बाद लाइव सेक्शन में
आइएगा। एसओसी की कोई सी भी क्लास की
वीडियो पहले क्लास की वीडियो को आप ओपन कर
लीजिएगा। यहां पे डिस्क्रिप्शन में दो
आपको लिंक्स मिलेंगे। एक WhatsApp चैनल का
और एक WhatsApp ग्रुप का। WhatsApp चैनल
को जरूर फॉलो कर लीजिएगा। 13,000 से
ज्यादा लोग हमसे जुड़े हुए हैं। इसके फ्री
ऑफ कॉस्ट आपको फॉलो करने का कोई पैसा नहीं
देना है। एंड यहां पे आपको हमारे तरफ से
जो भी अपडेट्स होती है सबसे पहले आपको इसी
WhatsApp चैनल पे मिलेंगी। रिगार्डिंग
एनीथिंग लाइक किसी भी तरह की अपडेट सबसे
पहले आपको इसी चैनल पे मिलेगी। चाहे किसी
भी तरह की ट्रेनिंग, कोर्सेज, ऑफर्स,
व्हाटएवर यू विल गेट हियर ओनली। उसके बाद
दूसरा लिंक है WhatsApp ग्रुप का जो कि एक
एसओसी इस सीरीज की स्पेसिफिक ग्रुप है।
जहां आपको सारे रिसोर्सेज, नोट्स या जो भी
अपडेट्स या जो भी इंफॉर्मेशनेशन होती है
इस सीरीज के रिगार्डिंग सबसे पहले आपको
एंड सिर्फ इसी ग्रुप में मिलती है। तो
दोनों को जॉइ जरूर कर लीजिएगा। साथ ही में
यहां पे हमारा Lindin पेज ये मेरा पर्सनल
Lindin पेज है। आप यहां पे आके इस यूजरनेम
आप देख सकते हैं ऊपर ये यूआरएल है। यहां
पे आके मुझे आप फॉलो कर सकते हैं। मुझसे
जुड़ सकते हैं। एंड यहां पे आप मुझसे
कनेक्ट हो सकते हैं। साथ ही में आप Lindin
पे अगर डिफ़्रॉनिक सर्च करेंगे तो
डिफ़्रॉनिक साइबर सिक्योरिटी का Lindin पेज
आपको देखने को मिल जाता है। यह हमारी
कंपनी का Lindin पेज है जिसको आप फॉलो
करके हमारी कंपनीज़ के तरफ से अपडेटेड रह
सकते हैं। व्हाटएवर अपडेट, व्हाटएवर
थिंग्स आर देयर यू विल बी अपडेटेड फ्रॉम
आवर ओन आवर कंपनी साइड एंड यहां पे
अलग-अलग तरह की चीजें होती रहती हैं।
अलग-अलग अपडेट्स, गिव अवेज़ ये सब चीजें
आपको यहां पे मिलती रहेंगी। यह Instagram
का प्रोफाइल है हमारा डिफ़्रॉनिक्स एकडमी
यूजर हैंडल जहां पे आपको इनेशनल, रील
कंटेंट्स, पोस्ट मिल जाएंगे जिससे आपको
काफी कुछ जानकारी मिलेगी, सीखने को मिलेगा
एथिकल हैकिंग एंड साइबर सिक्योरिटी में।
सो प्लीज इसको फॉलो जरूर जरूर कर लीजिएगा।
साथ ही में यहां पे ये हमारी वेबसाइट है
जो कि कंप्लीट अभी रीड कंप्लीट न्यू लुक
फील में आने वाला है। बहुत जल्द आपको
देखने को मिलेगा। इसको जरूर बुकमार्क करके
रखिएगा यहां से एंड विजिट करते रहिएगा।
आपको सारी अपडेट्स नई जो वेबसाइट आ रही है
उसमें बहुत कुछ आपको डिटेल में देखने को
मिल जाएगा। तो यह वेबसाइट पे आप अपडेटेड
रहिएगा। यहां हमारा नंबर है जिस पे आप
कांटेक्ट करके हमसे बातें कर सकते हैं।
हमसे कोई भी क्वेरी, कोई भी सजेशंस, कुछ
भी आपको बात करनी हो प्लीज WhatsApp अस ऑन
दिस नंबर। एकडमी पे जाके आप हमारे
कोर्सर्सेस को एक्सप्लोर कर सकते हैं जो
कि पावर्ड बाय डिफ्रॉनिक्स डिफ्रॉनिक्स के
तरफ से आपको मिल जाता है। एंड जो भी
कोर्सर्सेस में सर्टिफिकेशन आपको मिलते
हैं वेरीफाई योर सर्टिफिकेट्स पर जाके आप
उन सर्टिफिकेशंस को एक्सेस कर सकते हैं।
लाइक उन सर्टिफिकेशन को वेरीफाई कर सकते
हैं यहां पे नेम एंड सर्टिफिकेट आईडी डाल
के। सो ये भी हम आपको प्रोवाइड करते हैं।
यह मेरी पर्सनल Instagram पेज है। यू कैन
कम एंड कनेक्ट विद मी ऑन दिस हैंडल लिटिंग
हैकर। यू कैन कनेक्ट विद मी एंड देन
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] यहां पे आपको
हमारा एक्स का पेज मिल जाता है
डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी हैंडल के साथ। इसको भी
फॉलो कर लीजिएगा। दैट्स इट। सो ये थी पूरी
अ
कहानी अब तक की। अब जो है आज की जो क्लास
है उसमें हम पहले आगे की तरफ बढ़ते हैं।
एंड इट विल बी अमेजिंग सेशन। मजा आएगा
आपको। एंड यहां पे पूछ रहे हैं ने ग्रेस
मैन। सर योर क्लासेस आर सो इनफेटिव।
इनफेटिव बट स्टूडेंट्स लाइक मी लैक नॉलेज
ऑफ़ सम ऑफ़ द कीवर्ड्स दैट यू यू आर यूजिंग
इन क्लासेस। सो माय रिगार्ड यू प्लीज टू
एक्सप्लेन दोज़ वर्ड्स। कौन से कीवर्ड्स की
आप बात कर रहे हो? मुझे एक बार थोड़ा
आईडिया दो ताकि मुझे आईडिया लग जाए
एक्सैक्टली कि व्हाट कीवर्ड्स यू आर
एग्जैक्टली टॉकिंग अबाउट। राइट? ताकि
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] हम उसको मतलब
आपको बता सकें। चलिए तो आज के सेशन में हम
एक बहुत ही इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक पढ़ने वाले
हैं। एंड दैट इज़ नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी
एसेंशियल। अब एज एन एसओसी एनालिस्ट क्या
होता है कि आपका नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी का जो
है ना वो भी थोड़ा सा अ नॉलेज जो है थोड़ी
सी जो नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी की जो नॉलेज है
वो आपके पास होनी चाहिए। अगर आपके पास
नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी की नॉलेज नहीं है देन
आई थिंक कि आपका जो नॉलेज है एसओसी का 11
प्रोफाइल के लिए वो शायद अधूरा है थोड़ा
थोड़ा थोड़ा अधूरा है एंड उसको पूरा करेगा
आपको नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी का ये क्लास एंड
साथ ही नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी की नॉर्मल
नॉलेज जो है वो भी आपके अंदर होनी चाहिए।
अब मैं आपको एक चीज बता देता हूं। लेट
सपोज़ कि आपको बहुत इन डेप्थ नेटवर्क
सिक्योरिटी जानना है, पढ़ना है। तो मैं
आपको एक रिकमेंड करता हूं एक चीज। आप
हमारे YouTube देखो हमारे YouTube चैनल पे
सब चीज मिलेगा बट वही है कि आप खोज पाते
हैं कि नहीं खोज पाते हैं उस पे डिपेंड
करता है। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
देखो डिफर एकडमी YouTube चैनल पे जब आप
जाओगे तो यहां पे आपको हमारी जो प्लेलिस्ट
है ठीक है? आप उस प्लेलिस्ट को ओपन कर
लीजिएगा। ठीक है? लेट्स ओपन द प्लेलिस्ट।
प्लेलिस्ट को आप ओपन कर लीजिएगा।
प्लेलिस्ट ओपन जब आप करेंगे तो यहां पे इन
प्लेलिस्ट में जब आप नीचे की तरफ थोड़ा
आएंगे तो यहां पे आपको एक नेटवर्क
सिक्योरिटी फ्री ट्रेनिंग की प्लेलिस्ट
मिलेगी। ठीक है? [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
व्यू फुल कोर्स इस पे क्लिक कीजिएगा। तो
यहां पे आपको नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी की
क्लासेस देखने को मिलेंगी। एक क्लास का
एवरेज ड्यूरेशन है 1 घंटे का। यहां लगभग
आपको 13 वीडियो लगभग 13 14 घंटे की एक
क्लास आपको यह देखने को मिलेगी। आप
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] इन नेटवर्क
सिक्योरिटी की क्लासेस को जो ये 13
क्लासेस हैं, इनको प्लीज जरूर देख
लीजिएगा। यह बहुत इन डेप्थ नेटवर्क
सिक्योरिटी की क्लासेस हैं। एंड आपको मजा
आ जाएगा इन क्लासेस को देख के। नेटवर्क
सिक्योरिटी में आप एक इंटरमीडिएट लेवल तक
अपने आपको कह पाएंगे इन कोर्सेज को इन
क्लासेस को देखने के बाद। तो अगर किसी को
बहुत एक्सप्लोर करना है आई रिक्वेस्ट देम
टू प्लीज फॉलो दिस प्लेलिस्ट। ये आपके
एसओसी के लिए भी हेल्प करेगी। ओवरऑल आपको
नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी का भी नॉलेज प्रोवाइड
करेगी। ठीक है? चलिए अब आते हैं। ये लास्ट
क्लास नहीं है भाई। आएगी जल्दी। लास्ट
क्लास भी हो जाएगी। ठीक है? अब हम आते हैं
नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी एसेंशियल्स पे जिसको
हम आज पढ़ने और समझने वाले हैं जो कि आपके
लिए काफी ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट होने वाला है।
तो चलिए हम इसको देखते हैं। अब देखो
नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी जो है ना नेटवर्क जो
नेटवर्क है वो एक होता है। एक नेटवर्क की
बात करते हैं। ठीक है? अगर नेटवर्क की हम
बात करें तो नेटवर्क जो होते हैं वो
अलग-अलग कॉम्पोनेंट से मिलके बने होते
हैं। नेटवर्क मतलब कोई एक डिवाइस, एक
कंप्यूटर, एक एंड पॉइंट एक कोई डिवाइस
नहीं होती। दे आर मेड अप ऑफ ऑफ डिफरेंट
टाइप ऑफ कॉमोनेंट्स। राइट? अब सारे
कॉमोनेंट्स एक साथ मिलके एक सिक्योर
कम्युनिकेशन बनाते हैं। जिसके थ्रू वो
डेटा को एक्सचेंज करते हैं। डेटा ट्रांसफर
करना यानी भेजना, रिसीव करना एंड जो भी
ऑपरेशंस हैं वो सारी चीजें करते हैं। यही
एक नेट नेटवर्क कहलाता है। ठीक है? सॉरी
नितेश सर। आई वाज नितेश। इट्स नितेश। आई
वाज एब्सेंट और कोई बात नहीं। कोई बात
नहीं। इट्स ओके। इट्स ओके।
गो पोकी सर [हंसी]
पोकी कौन बोलता है भाई पु सर पुकी
सो अब वो [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
कॉम्पोनेंट्स कौन-कौन से हैं जो एक
नेटवर्क को फॉर्म करता है तो एक हमारा एंड
पॉइंट होता है द कॉम्पोनेंट इज़ वन वन ऑफ़ द
कॉम्पोनेंट इज़ एंड पॉइंट। दूसरा
कॉम्पोनेंट फाइल एंड डेटाबेस सर्व्सर्स
होते हैं। तीसरे कॉम्पोनेंट होते हैं
एप्लीकेशन सर्वर्स। चौथा कॉम्पोनेंट होता
है एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी या ऑथेंटिकेशन
सर्वर्स जिनको हम बोल सकते हैं। पांचवा
होता है राउटर्स एंड स्विचेस ये और छठा
होता है फायरवॉल्स या पेरामीटर डिवाइसेस।
ठीक है? ये सारी चीजें होती है। ये सारी
चीजें मिलके बनाती है आपका एक नेटवर्क। अब
इन सारी चीजों में क्या होता है? जैसे एंड
पॉइंट्स की जब हम बात करें तो एंड पॉइंट्स
क्या होते हैं? जैसे कि आपका डेस्कटॉप हो
गया, आपका लैपटॉप हो गया, आपका स्मार्टफोन
हो गया, टैबलेट हो गया, प्रिंटर हो गया,
आई ओटी डिवाइसेस हो गए। ये सब एंड पॉइंट्स
कहलाते हैं। फाइल्स एंड डेटाबेस सर्वर्स
की बात करें तो जो भी फाइल सर्वर्स जितने
भी हैं चाहे वो एसएमबीस हो गए, एनएस हो गए
या डेटाबेस सर्वर्स जैसे कि मायसक्यूएल या
एसक्यूएल व्हाटएवर वो सारे आपके फाइल या
डेटाबेस सर्वसर्स कहलाते हैं। एप्लीकेशन
सर्वर्स की बात करें तो जो वेब सर्वर्सर्स
होते हैं आपके ईमेल सर्वर्स होते हैं आपके
वीpए सर्वर्स होते हैं आपके या जो भी अदर
एप्लीकेशन रिलेटेड सर्वर्स हैं वो सारे
एप्लीकेशन सर्वर्स के अंदर में आ जाते
हैं। जैसे कि प्रोटोकॉल जैसे कि एचटीडीटीp
एचtडीपीएस हो गया, एसएमडीपी ये सब
प्रोटोकॉल्स उनके अंदर काम करते हैं।
एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी या ऑथेंटिकेशन सर्वर की
बात करें तो जो एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी होती है
वो इसमें आ जाती है। एलडप सर्वर्स जो लाइट
वेट एक्टिव जो
एलडप होती है सॉरी
जस्ट अ सेकंड गाइस।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
नहीं भाई हमें थंबनेल
प्लीज डोंट स्पैम आप स्पैम मत कीजिए
अदरवाइज आपको टाइम आउट करना पड़ेगा ठीक है
प्लीज डोंट स्पैम
सो [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] एक
डायरेक्टरीज इसमें होती है एल्डप सर्वर्स
इसमें होती हैं रेडियस या लाइक अलग-अलग
डाटास प्लस से अलग-अलग तरीके के आते हैं
सर्वर्स आते हैं वो सब इसमें इंक्लूडेड
होते हैं। सिंगल साइन ऑन जो एसएसओस होते
हैं वो सारे इसमें इंक्लूडेड होते हैं। तो
देयर आर मल्टीपल थिंग्स। अह ये सारी चीजें
एडी एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी ऑथेंटिकेशन सर्व
सर् में होते हैं। ये सब इसमें इंक्लूडेड
ये सब फॉर्म करते हैं मिलके नेटवर्क
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] को। अगर
राउटर एंड स्विचेस की बात करें तो
राउटर्स, स्विचेस ये सारे इसमें इंक्लूडेड
होते हैं। फायरवल पैरामीटर की बात करें तो
आपकी आईडीएस हो गए या फिर आई आईपीएस हो गई
या नेक्स्ट जनरेशन फायर वाल्स हो गए हैं
या [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] वेब
एप्लीकेशन फायर वाल्स जो होते हैं, गेटवेज़
होती हैं या पेरीमीटर
पेरीमीटर सिक्योरिटी डिवाइसेस होती है। ये
सारे जो हैं ये आपके होते हैं फायर फायर
वाल्स या पेरामीटर डिवाइसेस। अब ये छह के
छह कॉम्पोनेंट जो आपको दिख रहा होगा ये छह
कॉम्पोनेंट्स ये सारे मिलके क्या बनाते
हैं? एक नेटवर्क बनाते हैं। ये सारे मिल
जब जाते हैं तो नेटवर्क बना के काम क्या
करते हैं? कम्युनिकेशन इनेबल करते हैं।
डेटा को स्टोर और प्रोटेक्ट करते हैं।
सिक्योरिटी को इंश्योर करते हैं और बिनेस
ऑपरेशंस में सपोर्ट करते हैं। ये सारी
चीजें होती है नेटवर्क। इसको हम नेटवर्क
बोलते हैं। सिंपल है। बहुत सिंपली तरीके
से मैंने आपको बताया है। बट बिफोर एज एन
एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट एल1 बिफोर एज अ डिफेंडर
आप एक नेटवर्क को डिफेंड करो। उससे पहले
आपको इनका रोल इनकी वनेबिलिटी प्रोफाइल और
इनके जो एसेट टाइप है उनका रोल और
वनेबिलिटी प्रोफाइल यह समझना बहुत जरूरी
है। जैसे इसमें ऐसे टाइप्स होते हैं।
अलग-अलग तरह के ऐसे टाइप्स हैं
जिनके रोल्स और वनेबिलिटी प्रोफाइल को हम
समझेंगे और जानेंगे कि एक्सैक्टली व्हाट
दे आर, हाउ दे वर्क एंड उससे आपका और
क्लियर होता चला जाएगा। वो ऐसे टाइप्स के
बारे में आप और ज्यादा क्लियर हो जाएंगे।
तो हम उन ऐसे टाइप्स को थोड़ा हम समझते
हैं। ठीक है?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके।
अब हम एसेट टाइप की अगर बात करते हैं। ऐसे
टाइप्स में हमारे पास मल्टीपल एसेट टाइप्स
थे जो अभी हमने पढ़ा जो हमारे कॉम्पोनेंट्स
थे। हम उसी की बात कर रहे हैं। तो पहला
आपका आता है यूजर वर्क स्टेशन यानी कि एंड
पॉइंट्स। ठीक है? मैं इसका कलर थोड़ा चेंज
करता हूं। यूजर एंड पॉइंट्स यहां पे हम
करते हैं।
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके
हम
अ प्लीज डोंट स्पैम नेग्रे प्लीज डोंट
स्पैम ठीक है मैं आपके क्वेश्चन पे आ
जाऊंगा थोड़ी देर में पहला हमारा एंड
पॉइंट्स हो जाता है दूसरा हमारा फाइल एंड
डेटाबेस सर् हो गए तो इन सबके प्राइमरी
रोल्स के बारे में हम थोड़ा जानेंगे।
सिक्योरिटी रिस्क या अटैक वेक्टर्स के
बारे में जानेंगे। एंड मॉनिटरिंग
प्रायोरिटीज़ के बारे में थोड़ा हम समझेंगे।
सबसे पहले हम एंड पॉइंट्स की बात करें तो
इनका प्राइमरी रोल क्या होता है? डेली
एंप्लई टास्क। जैसे लैपटॉप, पीसी से आप
क्या करते हैं? डेली के टास्क वगैरह करते
हैं। वही सारे काम ये हमारा ये एंड पॉइंट
करता है। सिक्योरिटी रिस्क या अटैक
वेक्टर्स क्या है? इनसे कनेक्टेड तो इनके
ऊपर फिशिंग अटैक्स, मलशियस डाउनलोड्स,
इनिशियल एक्सेस फुट होल्ड ये सारी चीजें
हो सकती हैं। मॉनिटरिंग प्रायोरिटीज़ क्या
है कि ईडीआर एग्जीक्यूशन ऑफ़ अनअथराइज़्ड
स्क्रिप्ट्स, सस्िशियस आउटबाउंड ट्रैफिक
इन पे आपको इन चीजों को मॉनिटर करना है।
मतलब इन एंड पॉइंट्स के ऊपर ईडीआर सेटअप
हो जाएगा आपका। अनअथराइज़्ड स्क्रिप्ट्स को
मॉनिटर करना है कि कोई अनअथराइज़्ड
स्क्रिप्ट्स तो नहीं एग्जीक्यूट हो रही
है। या सस्िशियस आउटबाउंड ट्रैफिक। कोई
ट्रैफिक ऐसी तो नहीं है जो बाहर की तरफ जा
रही है। उसको भी आपको मॉनिटर करना है। ये
सारी चीजें आपको मॉनिटर करनी है। फाइल्स
एंड डेटाबेस सर्वर्स की हम बात करें तो ये
क्या करते हैं? इनका रोल क्या है?
सेंट्रलाइज्ड स्टोरेज फॉर सेंसिटिव बिनेस
डेटा। यह आपको प्रोवाइड करते हैं
सेंट्रलाइज्ड स्टोरेज। एक सेंसिटिव बिज़नेस
डेटा के लिए सेंट्रलाइज्ड स्टोरेज
प्रोवाइड करते हैं। जैसे कि अब इसमें हम
बात करते हैं इनसे रिलेटेड सिक्योरिटी
रिस्क क्या है? तो रैंसमवेयर इंक्रिप्शन
रैंसवेयर अटैक हो सकता है। ऑथराइज
अनअथराइज्ड एक्सफिल्ट्रेशन आपकी जो
सेंसिटिव डेटा है उसको बाहर किसी दूसरे
सर्वर पे भेजा जा सकता है। किसी दूसरे
लोकेशन पे भेजा जा सकता है। डेटा थप्ट
डेटा को चुराया जा सकता है। फाइल एंड
डेटाबेस सर्वर है। ऑब्वियस सी बात है। तो
इसमें आपको मॉनिटर क्या करना है? फाइल
एक्सेस लॉग्स कि उन फाइल्स को कौन-कौन
एक्सेस कर रहा है? अनयूजुअल बल्क रीड एंड
राइट्स। अनयूजुअल रीड एंड राइट कोई कर रहा
है क्या या हो रहा है क्या? अन ऑथराइज्ड
नेटवर्क कनेक्शंस। कोई ऐसे कनेक्शंस जो
अनथराइज्ड हो नेटवर्क के अंदर में वह
क्रिएट हो रहे हैं क्या? इन सब चीजों की
मॉनिटरिंग आपको करनी होती है इस तरीके से।
ठीक है?
अब [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] आते हैं
एप्लीकेशन सर्वर्स के ऊपर। एप्लीकेशन
सर्वर्स में मतलब वेब सर्वर हो गया, ईमेल
सर्वर हो गया, वीपीएस हो गया। इन सब की हम
बात कर रहे हैं।
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
तो यहां पे प्राइमरी
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] रोल क्या है?
एक्सटर्नली एंड इंटरनली एक्सपोज्ड
एंटरप्राइज सर्विज। अब इनका काम होता है
कि ये एक्सटर्नल सर्विसेस जो होते हैं और
इंटरनल सर्विज को मिलाते हैं। ठीक है?
कनेक्ट करते हैं। इनका यही काम है। वीpए
का भी काम क्या है? एक रिमोट सिक्योर लॉग
इन कोई कर सके आपके इंटरनल नेटवर्क के
अंदर में। जैसे कोई एंप्लई है किसी कंपनी
के सर्वर से जुड़ना चाहता है या किसी
कंपनी के नेटवर्क में घुस के कोई काम करना
चाहता है कंपनी के नेटवर्क के अंदर ही तो
वो वीpए का यूज़ करेगा। अगर वो कंपनी में
नहीं है, किसी दूसरे सिटी में है, कहीं और
है तो वीpए के थ्रू कंपनी के नेटवर्क से
कनेक्ट हो सकता है। जैसे आप ट्राई हैक के
अंदर में ना वीपीए के थ्रू कनेक्ट कर सकते
हैं। ओपन वीपीए का उन्होंने ऑप्शन दिया
हुआ है। तो अगर आपको ट्राईकमी के नेटवर्क
का कोई सर्वर, कोई कंप्यूटर या कोई भी
आईपी एक्सेस करनी होती है तो आप अपने
नेटवर्क से नहीं कर सकते। बिकॉज़ यू आर नॉट
द पार्ट ऑफ़ दैट ट्राईक नेटवर्क। योर
नेटवर्क इज़ अ डिफरेंट नेटवर्क सिचुएटेड इन
अदर कंट्री इन अदर सिटी। ट्राईकमी इस
सर्वर्स या ट्रायकमी का वो जो नेटवर्क है
वो जो कंप्यूटर है वो जो सर्वर है वो किसी
और कंट्री वो किसी और सिटी में है तो आप
अपने से उससे कैसे कनेक्ट कर सकते हो उसके
सिस्टम को कैसे एक्सेस कर सकते हो उसके
लिए आपको उसके नेटवर्क में घुसना पड़ेगा
और वो नेटवर्क में घुसने के लिए आपको वीpए
का एक्सेस प्रोवाइड करते हैं। वो वीpए का
एक
माध्यम आपको प्रोवाइड करते हैं। उसी
मीडियम से आप उनके नेटवर्क को एक्सेस कर
सकते हैं। एंड यू कैन जस्ट यूज़ देम ओपन
वीpए राइट। सो यहां पे एप्लीकेशन सर्वर्स
पे सिक्योरिटी रिस्क क्या-क्या होते हैं?
एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन हो सकता है। अनपैच्ड
सॉफ्टवेयर एक्सप्लइट्स जो हैं उनको
एग्जीक्यूट किया जा सकता है। ब्रूट फ़ोर्स
किया जा सकता है। आपको क्या मॉनिटर करनी
है? तो एप्लीकेशन वेब लॉग्स जो एप्लीकेशन
के या वेब सर्वर पे कोई एप्लीकेशन चल रहा
है उनके वेब लॉग्स को आप मॉनिटर करें। वेब
अलर्ट वेब एप्लीकेशन फायरवल के अलर्ट्स को
मॉनिटर करें कि भाई कोई ऐसा है तो नहीं
बाईपास करने की कोशिश कर रहा है। फेल्ड
ऑथेंटिकेशन अटेम्प्ट्स ऐसे ऑथेंटिकेशन
अटेम्प्ट जो कि फेल हो जा रहे हैं या फेल
हो जा फेल हो गए हैं तो उनको आप मॉनिटर
करें कि भाई ऐसा क्या रिपीटेड ऑथेंटिकेशन
ट्राई मारा जा रहा है। बहुत बार कोई ट्राई
मार रहा है। उनको आप जरूर मॉनिटर कीजिए।
एज एन एन एन एन एन एन एन एन एन एन एसोसिएट
एनालिस्ट एज एन एसोसिए एल1 ये काम आपके
होंगे। आपको मॉनिटरिंग का काम एल एल1 का
रोल जो होता है ना मोस्टली मॉनिटरिंग का
काम और एस्केलेशन का काम होता है ज्यादा
जितने अच्छे से आप नेटवर्क को मॉनिटर कर
पाएंगे जितनी ज्यादा नॉलेज आपको होगी
रिस्क्स की थ्रेट्स की अटैक्स की
वनेबिलिटीज अलग-अलग तरह के किस तरह की
वनेबिलिटीज होते हैं उनके क्या
एक्सप्लइट्स हैं क्या सीवीज करेंटली अभी
ज्यादा एक्सप्लइट हो रही हैं किस तरह के
अटैक्स नेटवर्क्स किस तरह की चीजों को
ज्यादा अटैकर्स टारगेट करते हैं उतना
ज्यादा आपके लिए अच्छा होगा उतने ज्यादा
बेटर आप एसओसी एल1 कहलाएंगे। दैट्स इट
कंपनी के अंदर। अब एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी
आइडेंटिटी सर्वर या ऑथेंटिकेशन सर्वर की
हम बात करें इनका प्राइमरी रोल क्या है?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ये आइडेंटिटी बैकबोन मैनेजिंग यूजर्स
परमिशंस एंड डोमेन ऑब्जेक्ट्स होते हैं।
ये किसी भी नेटवर्क का किसी भी एक बड़े
नेटवर्क का छोटे नेटवर्क का नहीं छोटे
नेटवर्क्स में एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी नहीं
होती है। छोटी का छोटी कंपनी है उनका छोटा
अगर नेटवर्क इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर है वहां
एक्टिव डायरेक्टरीज काम नहीं करती है। ये
एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी जो होती है वो बड़े
नेटवर्क का पार्ट होती है। तो इनका ये
सबसे इनका जो मेजर काम होता है यह एक बड़े
लाइक बैकबोन होते हैं।
लाइक
सर आई हैव ऑलरेडी एक्सप्लेन ऑल दिस
यस आई हैव ऑलरेडी एक्सप्लेन राइट PUBG बट
ठीक है मैं देख लेता हूं उसको देख लूंगा
अभी आइडेंटिटी बैकबोन मतलब कि जितने भी
आइडेंटिटी रिलेटेड चीजें होती हैं वो
एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी करती है जैसे कि यूजर्स
की आइडेंटिटी की बात हो उनके मैनेज करने
की बात हो यूजर्स परमिशंस की बात हो ठीक
है या डोमेन ऑब्जेक्ट्स या डोमेन कंट्रोलर
या व्हाटएवर डोमेनस के अंदर जो भी चीजें
हो एक नेटवर्क के अंदर में उन सब की
आइडेंटिटी की यानी किस यूजर को किस चीज का
कितना एक्सेस है इसका मैनेजमेंट सब एक्टिव
डायरेक्टरी के अंदर होता है। ठीक है? जैसे
आप एक यूजर हो तो आप किस चीज को किस ग्रुप
के साथ कितना और कब तक एक्सेस कर सकते हो।
किस चीज के लिए आप अलाउड हो यह एक्टिव
डायरेक्टरी मैनेज करती है आइडेंटिटी एंड
परमिशन वाला चीज सब कुछ एवरीथिंग
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन इसमें सिक्योरिटी
रिस्क क्या है तो प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशंस हो
सकते हैं ठीक है करबेरोस्टिंग कर्वेस्ट से
रिलेटेड एक लाइक अटैक है वो हो सकती है
पासवर्ड स्प्रेइंग पासवर्ड मल्टीपल
पासवर्ड फेल्ड पासवर्ड अटेम्प्ट्स ट्राई
मारते हैं करते रहते हैं पासवर्ड
स्प्रेइंग हो सकती है लेटरल मूवमेंट एक
नेटवर्क के अंदर एक डिवाइस से दूसरे
डिवाइस में मूव ऑन करना ये काम हो सकता है
आपको मॉनिटर फिर क्या करना है? स्ट्रीम इज
बफरिंग। नो नो स्ट्रीम इज नॉट बफरिंग एट
ऑल। आई डोंट थिंक सो मैं लेट मी चेक वंस।
नहीं स्ट्रीम बफर नहीं कर रही है। अगर
आपके लिए बफर कर रही है तो आपके साइड कुछ
नेटवर्क इशू होगा इसलिए। सो प्लीज चेक योर
नेटवर्क साइट। स्ट्रीम अभी बफर नहीं हो
रही है। ठीक है? बिल्कुल सही चल रही है
स्ट्रीम। इज द स्ट्रीम गोइंग स्मूथ फॉर
एवरीबॉडी? मुझे एक बार बता दीजिए क्योंकि
मेरे लिए यह स्मूथ चल रही है। अभी मुझे
कोई बफरिंग या कुछ ऐसा दिख नहीं रहा है।
तो मैं चाहता हूं कि बाकी लोग भी बताएं एक
बार कि सबके लिए सही है स्ट्रीम।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
इट्स ओके।
ठीक है? तो यहां पे मॉनिटरिंग एक्टिविटी
में क्या करना है? ऑथेंटिकेशन लॉग्स। जो
भी ऑथेंटिकेशन रिलेटेड लॉ्स हैं उनको
मॉनिटर करना है। डोमेन एडमिन, लॉग ऑन
इवेंट्स। डोमेन एडमिन में डोमेन का जो
एडमिन है वहां पे कोई लॉग इन वगैरह हो रहे
हैं उसके इवेंट्स को एंड ऑफ आवर एक्सेस
मतलब कि जनरली जब एंप्लाइजज़ नहीं होते हैं
जनरली ऑफिस का टाइम नहीं होता है उस टाइम
में भी कोई एक्सेस करने की कुछ कोशिश कर
रहा है या अटेम्प्ट्स हो रहे हैं उनको भी
आपको मॉनिटर करना है उसके बाद
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] है राउटर्स एंड
स्विचेस के ऊपर राउटर स्विचेस के बारे में
आपको पता है राउटर राउटिंग के लिए यूज़
होता है आपके नेटवर्क से बाहर के नेटवर्क
से कनेक्ट करने के लिए स्विचेस मल्टीपल
नेटवर्क डिवाइसेस को कनेक्ट करने के लिए
यूज़ में लिया जाता है तो इसका रोल है
नेटवर्क इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर डायरेक्टिंग
इंटरनल लैंड ट्रैफिक एंड इंटरनेट राउटिंग।
सो बेसिकली इंटरनल लैंड ट्रैफिक को यह
डायरेक्ट करता है बाहर की दुनिया की तरफ
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] और इंटरनेट
राउटिंग करता है। मतलब इंटरनेट से आपको
कनेक्ट कराता है आपको बाहर की दुनिया से
बाहर की दुनिया को आपसे वगैरह-वगैरह ये सब
इनका काम है। इस पे किस तरह के सिक्योरिटी
रिस्क है? तो मैन इन द मिडिल अटैक कर सकता
है अटैकर। ठीक है? ट्रैफिक को इंटरसेप्ट
किया जा सकता है। रोग राउट राउटिंग पाथ्स
यानी कि आपका आपने रिक्वेस्ट कहीं और भेजा
और आपकी रिक्वेस्ट वहां ना जाके किसी एक
मलेशियस सर्वर पे चली गई। किसी एक मलेशियस
डोमेन पे मलेशियस सी2 सर्वर जो अटैकर
कंट्रोलोल्ड है वहां पे आपकी रिक्वेस्ट
चली गई। यानी कि आप अनइटेंशनली एक मलेशियस
जगह पे अपनी रिक्वेस्ट भेज दे रहे हैं या
मलेशियस जगह से कनेक्ट हो जा रहे हैं। दैट
इज़ राउटिंग रोग राउटिंग पाथ्स। यहां पे
आपको क्या करना है? है एज अ मॉनिटरिंग
नेटवर्क कॉन्फ़िगरेशन चेंजज़। अगर नेटवर्क
में किसी तरह का कॉन्फ़िगरेशन चेंजज़ हो रहा
है और आपको लग रहा है कि यह कॉन्फ़िगरेशन
चेंजज़ हमने नहीं किया या किसी ऑथराइज़्ड
पर्सन ने नहीं किया है कुछ या फिर थोड़ा सा
वो अजीब सा एनोमेली टाइप दिख रहा है आपको
लाइक कुछ भी हो रहा है तो आपको उसको ध्यान
में देना चाहिए। फ्लो डेटा यहां पे डेटा
का फ्लो कैसा हो रहा है? बहुत ज्यादा
अमाउंट में डेटा फ्लो तो नहीं हो रहा।
बहुत ज्यादा अमाउंट में कोई डेटा पैकेट
फ्लो तो नहीं हो रही है। ये भी आपको चेक
करते रहना है। ठीक है? तो ये सारी चीजें
इसमें होती है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
अब आते हैं फायरवल या पेरीमीटर डिवाइसेस।
फायरवल या पेरामीटर डिवाइस मतलब जो आपके
नेटवर्क इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर की सिक्योरिटी
पूरे चारों तरफ से कर रहा है। तो प्राइमरी
गेटवे इंस्पेक्टिंग एंड फिल्टरिंग ट्रैफिक
बिटवीन ट्रस्टेड एंड अनट्रस्टेड नेटवर्क।
सिंपल सा है यहां पे यह पैरामीटर का मतलब
है कि एक आपके इंटरनल सिक्योर नेटवर्क को
बाहर के अनसिक्योर नेटवर्क से बचाना। बाहर
के अनसिक्यर्ड ट्रैफिक से बचाना। आपके
इंटरनल सिक्योर ट्रैफिक को बाहर के
अनसिक्योर ट्रैफिक से बचाने का काम
पेरीमीटर डिवाइसेस या फिर फायर वाल्स करती
हैं। ठीक है? जो भी इनबाउंड यानी कि जो भी
कनेक्शंस इनबाउंड और आउटबाउंड होते हैं।
एक आपके तरफ से आपके नेटवर्क से बाहर की
तरफ जा रहे हैं और बाहर की तरफ नेटवर्क से
आपके नेटवर्क में आ रहे हैं जो ट्रैफिक्स
उनको फ़िल्टर करने का काम करती है। कि कोई
मेलिसियस पैकेट मेसियस डाटा तो नहीं आ रही
है अंदर। उनको फिल्टर करने का काम ये करती
है। तो सिक्योरिटी रिस्क क्या है? मिस
कॉन्फिगरर्ड रूल्स। अगर फायर वॉल के रूल्स
मिसकर्ड हो तो हो सकता है मलेशियस पैकेट्स
आपके नेटवर्क में घुस जाए और आपके नेटवर्क
के अंदर घुस के तबाही मचाएंगे। बाईपास
अटेमप्ट्स बाईपास कर दें आपके नेटवर्क की
सिक्योरिटी को फायरवल सिक्योरिटी को या
डीडीओएस जब बाईपास हो जाएगी ऐसी रूल्स के
कारण एंड आउट इनबाउंड जब आपको नेटवर्क के
बाहर से आपके नेटवर्क पे अनलिमिटेड
पैकेट्स भी आ सकते हैं। तो वहां डीडीओएस
डिस्ट्रीब्यूटेड डिनव सर्विस टाइप के
अटैक्स हो सकते हैं। एंड वहां पर फिर एक
लार्ज नंबर ऑफ पैकेट्स आपके नेटवर्क की
तरफ ट्रैवल कर सकती है और आपके नेटवर्क को
कंजेस्ट कर सकती है। जहां नेटवर्क कंजेशन
हो जाएगा तो वो एक नेटवर्क डीडीओएस
नेटवर्क डिस्ट्रीब्यूट डिस्ट्रीब्यूटेड इन
सर्विसेस कहलाएगा। जहां पे आपका नेटवर्क
जो है सर्विज देना बंद कर देगा। आपके
नेटवर्क से आप कुछ कर नहीं पाएंगे। अलाउ
यहां पे आपको चेक क्या करना होता एज एन
एसोसिएल वन कनेक्शन अलाउड या ब्लॉक्ड
लॉग्स मतलब आपको देखना है अलाउड या
ब्लॉक्ड लॉ्स में कनेक्शन किस तरह के हैं
कौन से अलाउड है क्या ब्लॉक्ड है पोर्ट
स्कैन अलर्ट्स पोर्ट स्कैनिंग तो नहीं चल
रही है भाई किसी की अटैकर के साइड से उसका
आपको देखना है वीपीए कनेक्शन लॉक्स वीपीए
जो है उसके थ्रू कनेक्ट करने का लॉग आपको
देखना है कि वीpए से कौन-कौन कनेक्टेड हैं
किस तरह के कनेक्शंस बने हैं ये सारी चीज़
आपको देखनी है एज एन एसओसी एलो तो ये पूरी
की पूरी जो है आपकी ऐसे एसेट टाइप्स थे।
ये जो सबसे पहला कॉलम है वो एसेट टाइप का
था। दूसरा कॉलम जो है वो प्राइमरी रोल
इनका था। तीसरा कॉलम इनका सिक्योरिटी
रिस्क इनसे रिलेटेड सिक्योरिटी रिस्क इनसे
जुड़े सिक्योरिटी रिस्क एंड अटैक वेक्टर्स
थे। और जो फोर्थ कॉलम था वो था मॉनिटरिंग
प्रायोरिटी। मतलब आपको क्या मॉनिटर करना
है इस पर्टिकुलर एसेट टाइप के लिए। आई होप
कि आपको ये चीजें बहुत क्लियर हो गई
होंगी। क्योंकि पूरी जो नेटवर्क
सिक्योरिटी एसेंशियल क्लास है हमारी वो इन
चीजों पे बहुत डिपेंड करती है कि इन चीजों
का आपको नॉलेज लेकर रखना है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] मैंने पहले
ही बोला है कि कोई भी कोई भी मेंटोर जो
होता है या टीचर या ट्रेनर
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़] वो आपको गाइड
करता है। वो आपको चीजों को कोर लेवल पे
सिखाता है, पढ़ाता है। बट जब तक आप खुद से
भी एक्सप्लोर नहीं करेंगे, आप कुछ नहीं कर
पाएंगे। लिटरली क्योंकि अगर सिर्फ स्कूल
और कॉलेज की पढ़ाई से साइंटिस्ट कोई बन
जाए तो ऐसा तो मैं मान नहीं सकता ना ही
आपको कोई ऐसा मिलेगा जो सिर्फ स्कूल या
कॉलेज से पढ़ के साइंटिस्ट बन गया हो या
कोई बहुत बड़ा लाइक सक्सेसफुल एक इंसान बन
चुका हो उसने खुद से चीजों को एक्सप्लोर
करा है। राइट? आइंस्टीन वाज़ नॉट आइंस्टीन
बिकॉज़ ऑफ़ कॉलेज और स्कूल राइट? आइंस्टीन
वाज़ आइंस्टीन बिकॉज़ ऑफ़ द आइंस्टीन। बिकॉज़
ऑफ ह लव ह पैशन फॉर रिसर्च फिजिक्स
एक्स्रा एक्सट्रा तो वह आपके अंदर होनी
चाहिए। अगर आपके अंदर वो है ना तो आपको
कोई रोक नहीं सकता है। मैं इतना ही
बोलूंगा आपको गाइडेंस है वो मैं आपको दे
रहा हूं। सो मैं आपसे एक रिक्वेस्ट करूंगा
कि जो भी पॉइंट्स जो भी आपके कीवर्ड जो भी
पॉइंट्स आपको लगता है कि
ये इंपॉर्टेंट है जैसे मैंने एसेट टाइप्स
बताए इसमें सारे जो हैं वोेंट्स हैं। अब
उन पॉइंट्स को यू कैन गेट एंड यू कैन जस्ट
एक्सप्लोर।
आपके पास एक्सप्लोर करने के लिए देयर आर
लॉट ऑफ़ थिंग्स इन नाउ अ डज़। आज के टाइम
में ना बहुत चीजें हैं।
आपके पास पूरी की पूरी चैट जीपीटी है,
क्लाउड है, जेमिनाई है। आपके पास Google
वि AI है। पता नहीं क्या है। तो अब उसका
बेनिफिट लो। उसका फायदा उठाओ। क्योंकि
उसका फायदा उठाओगे तभी कोई फायदा है एआई
का। यू कैन गो थ्रू एवरीथिंग।
बस।
ठीक है? समझ में आया? तो यहां तक सभी को
समझ में आया? मुझे एक बार बताइए। जल्दी से
बताइए। एवरीबॉडी प्लीज लेट मी नो इफ यू
अंडरस्टुड टेल हियर
सभी लोग बताइए [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
एवरीबडी प्लीज
क्लियर
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके ओके गुड
ओके सो अब बढ़ते हैं हम नेक्स्ट टॉपिक की
तरफ। एंड हम [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
इसका एक डेमोंस्ट्रेशन भी देखेंगे। सो
उसके लिए आपको बेफिक्र रहना है।
डेमोंस्ट्रेशन वी विल आल्सो सी। नेटवर्क
विजिबिलिटी के बारे में थोड़ा हम जानते हैं
जिसमें हम होस्ट सेंट्रिक वर्सेस नेटवर्क
सेंट्रिक लॉग्स के बारे में जानेंगे जो कि
बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट चीज है। देखो अ फंडामेंटल
प्रिंसिपल फॉर सिक्योरिटी एनालिस्ट इज़ यू
कैन नॉट डिफेंड व्हाट यू कैन नॉट सी। अब
यार मान लो आप किसी चीज को देख ही नहीं पा
रहे हो। तो आप उसको डिफेंड कैसे करोगे?
उसके लिए डिफेंस मैकेनिज्म तैयार कैसे
करोगे? डिफेंस अप्रोच कैसे तैयार करोगे?
है ना? होलोमैन को कैसे पकड़ोगे? राइट?
होलोमैन जो दिखता ही नहीं है। तो जो आप
चीज़ को देख नहीं सकते उसको आप डिफेंड कैसे
करोगे? तो यू नीड टू सी एवरीथिंग इन अ
नेटवर्क। हर चीज आपको देखना है, दिखना
चाहिए। देन यू कैन डिफेंड द नेटवर्क।
दैट्स द मेन थिंग। कंप्लीट विजिबिलिटी
रिक्वायर्स कंबाइनिंग इंटरनल सिस्टम डेटा
विद एज ट्रैफिक रिकॉर्स। एक कंप्लीट
विजिबिलिटी होनी चाहिए एंड तब आप एक
डिफेंस तैयार कर सकते हो अपने नेटवर्क को
बचाने के लिए किसी भी कंपनी के। ठीक है?
इंटरव्यू प्रिपरेशन के लिए अ
मैं बताऊंगा
इंटरव्यू प्रिपरेशन के लिए आपके जब यह
क्लासेस खत्म हो जाएंगे तो आई विल लेट यू
नो।
आई विल लेट यू नो मैं सभी को बताऊंगा उसके
लिए बेफिक्र रहिए आप लोग आपको काफी हेल्प
होगी उस इंटरव्यू प्रिपरेशन अ जो मैं आपको
तरीका बताऊंगा एंड देन यू कैन अप्लाई फॉर
द देखो अभी भी आप लोग अगर खुद से भी
एक्सप्लोर करते हैं तो यू आर रेडी टू
अप्लाई फॉर जॉब्स। आप अभी उस जगह पे पहुंच
चुके हो एसओसी क्लासेस के थ्रू कि आप
इंटरव्यूज के लिए अप्लाई करना शुरू कर
सकते हो। थोड़ी इस प्लंक के ऊपर एक्सप्लोर
कर लेना। इस प्लंक को यूज करने का। जैसे
मैंने आपको तो पूरा बताया हुआ है। स्प्लंक
कैसे यूज़ करना है। राइट? थोड़ी खुद से भी
एक्सप्लोर कर लेना। बाकी थ्योरिटिकल नॉलेज
और जो कांसेप्ट्स है उसको दिमाग में रखना।
दैट्स इट। यू आर रेडी फॉर द इंटरव्यू।
क्योंकि अब कुछ ही चीजें हैं जो बची हैं।
उसके बाद हमारा इंटरव्यू कैसे क्या करना
है वो पार्ट ही आएगा हमारा। दैट्स इट। इस
सीरीज को फिर हम एंड करेंगे।
दैट्स [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] द
थिंग।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ठीक है?
तो चलिए यहां पर दो चीजें होती है। एक
होता है होस्ट सेंट्रिक लॉक, एक होता है
नेटवर्क सेंट्रिक लॉक। पहले हम होस्ट
सेंट्रिक लॉक्स पे बात करते हैं। यानी हम
इनसाइड द रूम की बात कर रहे हैं। दूसरा है
नेटवर्क सेंटर नेटवर्क सेंट्रिक लॉक्स।
इसका हम इसकी हम बात करेंगे किस चीज के
लिए? बिल्डिंग पेरामीटर एंड कॉरिडर्स।
मतलब हम पहले एक रूम के अंदर की बात
करेंगे। फिर हम रूम के बाहर की जो अ
बाउंड्रीज होती हैं, पेरीमीटर होती हैं,
उसकी बात करेंगे। तो पहले तो हम घर
बनाएंगे। फिर बाहर की दीवारें खड़ी
करेंगे। उसका बाउंड्री वगैरह स्टार्ट हम
देंगे ताकि बाहर से सिक्योरिटी हमें मिल
जाए। राइट? तो जनरेटेड डायरेक्टली बाय
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम्स एंड एंड पॉइंट
सिक्योरिटी टूल्स। ये होस्ट सेंटरिंग
लॉक्स जो है वो कौन जनरेट करता है?
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम्स आपके जनरेट करती है और
एंड पॉइंट सिक्योरिटी टूल्स जनरेट करती
है। जैसे ईडीआर वगैरह है वो सब जनरेट करती
है। अब इसमें की सोर्सर्सेस क्या हैं?
उसको हम देखते हैं। Windows इवेंट लॉग्स
जो है ये इसके सोर्सेस हैं। यहां से आप इन
होस्ट सेंट्रिक लॉग्स को उठा सकते हो
फर्दर एग्जामिनेशन के लिए, फर्दर रिसर्च
के लिए। यानी कि Windows इवेंट लॉग्स जो
होते हैं जिसमें कि सिक्योरिटी लॉग्स हो
गए हैं, सिस्टम लॉग्स हो गए, एप्लीकेशन
लॉग्स हो गए। उन सब की बात कर रहा हूं।
Linux में Linux sis log होता है। उसको आप
यूज कर सकते हैं। Mac OS में Mac OS
यूनिफाइड लॉग्स होते हैं। Mac OS के अंदर
में इनका नाम है Mac OS यूनिफाइड लॉग्स या
ईडीआर या एंटीवायरस अलर्ट्स जो ईडीआर होते
हैं एंड पॉइंट डिटेक्शन जो
टूल्स होते हैं वो ईडीआर या एंटीवायरस के
जो अलर्ट्स हैं छोटी कंपनीज़ होगी तो
एंटीवायरस का यूज़ करते हैं। बड़ी नेटवर्क
या बड़ी वो होगी तो ईडीआर वगैरह यूज़ करते
हैं। ठीक है? ठीक है? तो इडीआर एंटीरस के
अलर्ट्स ये इसके सोर्सेस है जहां से ये
लॉक्स आप उठा सकते हो। ये होस्ट सेंट्रिक
लॉक्स क्या रिवील करते हैं? व्हाट दे
रिवील? यह रिवील करते हैं प्रोसेस क्रिएशन
कि कोई मलशियस प्रोसेस क्रिएट तो नहीं हो
गई है। cmd.exc
या पावर शेल.exc जैसी प्रोसेससेस कोई
मलेशियस तो नहीं क्रिएट हो गई या नॉर्मल
भी क्रिएट हुई है। तो ये उन लॉग्स को
बताता है। किसी भी तरह का कोई प्रोसेस
क्रिएट होगा। चाहे वह मलेशियस हो या जेरिक
लॉक्स हो या नॉर्मल लॉक्स हो यह आपको
बताएगा। उसी में आपको फिर आपको फर्दर
इन्वेस्टिगेट करना है। पता करना है कि
भैया कोई मलेशियस प्रोसेस भी क्रिएट हुई
है क्या?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
फाइल मॉडिफिकेशंस किसी तरह का भी
मॉडिफिकेशन आप करेंगे। आप जेरिक नॉर्मल
मॉडिफिकेशन भी करेंगे या मेलिसिस
मॉडिफिकेशन वो सब यह आपको बताता है।
सिस्टम रजिस्ट्री एडिट्स रजिस्ट्री के
अंदर में किसी तरह का
चेंज हुआ है। किसी तरह की कोई चेंजेस किए
गए हैं वो आपको यह बताता है। यूजर लॉग इन
या लॉगउ इवेंट्स। यूजर ने कब लॉग इन किया,
कब लॉगउ किया? ये सारी चीजें इवेंट्स जो
है ये भी कैप्चर की जाती हैं। बाय होस्ट
सेंट्रल क्लॉक्स आपको प्रोवाइड की जाती
है। टीचिंग एनालॉगी की हम बात करें
एनालॉजी की बात करें तो यहां पे होस्ट
लॉग्स टेल यू ये आपको क्या सिखाता है? ये
आपको क्या टीच करता है? टीचिंग अगर
एनालॉगी की बात करें हम तो होस्ट लॉग्स
टेल्स यू व्हाट हैपेंड इनसाइड अ स्पेसिफिक
रूम। तो यह जो एनालॉग है यह क्या बताता है
कि
रूम के अंदर में यह जो लॉग्स है यह बताता
है कि रूम के अंदर एक्सजेक्टली क्या हुआ
है? एग्जैक्टली क्या हुआ रूम के अंदर यह
बताता है। यह होते हैं होस्ट सेंट्रिक
लॉग्स।
हेलो भैया। आई वांटेड आई वांडर्ड अराउंड
फॉर टू इयर्स एंड केम बैक टू यू। आई लुक्ड
एवरीवेयर बट नो वन रीड्स लाइक यू। थैंक यू
वेरी मच ब्रदर फॉर योर
व्हाट्स? आई एम ग्लैड।
चलिए
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
गौरव इज़ सेइंग सर आई एम फॉलोइंग योर
वीडियोस मेकिंग नोट्स अलोंग विथ लैब्स देन
रिवाइज़ देम। मेक फ्लैश कार्ड्स। ग्रेट। गो
थ्रू देम एंड गिव अ क्विज़ टेस्ट एववरी
वीक। इज़ इट द राइट वे टू स्टडी फॉर
बिल्डिंग स्किल्स टू गेट हार्ड। इट्स द
बेस्ट वे आई थिंक यू आर यू आर डूइंग अ
ग्रेट।
यू आर हैविंग अ ग्रेट अप्रोच। गौरव प्लीज
कीप इट अप। एंड बहुत लोग ऐसा नहीं कर पाते
हैं। आई थिंक एवरीवन शुड फॉलो व्हाट गौरव
एंड हाउ गौरव इज़ डूइंग। सो यू कैन यूज़ द
अप्रोच। अप्रोच फॉलो करना कोई गलत बात
नहीं है। कॉपी नहीं है। कोई चीज़ अच्छी हो
तो कॉपी करना चाहिए। सो यू शुड एवरीवन शुड
कॉपी। व्हाट द लास्ट लेट अस कमेंट रीड्स
ऑफ़ गौरव कि ये सिंपली क्या करते हैं?
वीडियोस देखते हैं, नोट्स बनाते हैं एंड
लैब्स सॉल्व करते हैं। फिर उनसे फ्लैश
कार्ड्स जनरेट करते हैं। फ्लैश कार्ड्स
बनाते हैं एंड उन उनको गो थ्रू करते रहते
हैं फॉर रिवीजन एंड फॉर लाइक एवरीथिंग।
एंड फिर वो क्विज टेस्ट भी देते हैं टू
टेस्ट देर नॉलेज और स्किल्स। इट्स द गुड
वे।
ठीक है? इट्स द गुड वे।
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
ओके। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
अ नोट्स बनाने की बात मैं एक बार रिपीट
करना चाहूंगा फॉर एवरीबॉडी एवरीबडी फॉर
एवरीबॉडी
तो अभी हमने जो
एथिकल हैकिंग की वन शॉट वीडियो को 5:30
घंटे की डाली थी पार्ट वन उसके जो हमारे
सपोर्ट ग्रुप हमने बनाया WhatsApp पे। ठीक
है? तो उस ग्रुप में कई लोगों ने मैसेज
किया था कि सर हमें नोट्स दे दो इस कोर्स
का जो आपके पास है या व्हाटएवर
वी डिनाइड सिंपली वी डोंट बिलीव इन
शेयरिंग नोट्स लाइक सच यहां एस एस यहां जो
मैंने एसओसी का नोट्स आपको शेयर करा था वो
मैंने शेयर तो कर दिया बट मैंने आपको
बार-बार बोला था हमेशा कि आप खुद के भी
नोट्स बनाइए तो इट शुड बी योर हैबिट यू
शुड डेवलप दिस हैबिट कि आपको खुद के नोट्स
बनाने हैं। यू हैव टू मेक योर ओन नोट्स।
दैट विल ओनली हेल्प यू। किसी और का बना
बनाया बनाया नोट्स से आप कभी नहीं पढ़
सकते। आप कभी भी नहीं बेस्ट कर सकते। कभी
भी आप रियल स्किल्स आपके अंदर नहीं डेवलप
हो पाएंगी। क्योंकि वो तो बनी बनाई चीजें
मिल गई ना आपको। बनी बनाया बना बनाया मतलब
ऑलरेडी प्रिपयर्ड अगर मील आपको दे दिया
जाए, खाना दे दिया जाए तो आपको यह आप उसको
बना कैसे सकते हो? आपको तो बनाना आएगा
नहीं। आपको बनाना तब आएगा जब आप खुद से
खाना प्रिपेयर करने की कोशिश करो।
इंग्रेडिएंट्स को समझो। इंग्रेडिएंट्स को
डालो। प्रॉपर पोर्शन में डालो। प्रॉपर हीट
पे, प्रॉपर उस पे फ्लेम पे उसको कुक करो।
प्रॉपर टाइम के लिए। तब जाके एक बेटर मील
आप तैयार कर सकते हो, खाना तैयार कर सकते
हो। है ना? जिसमें फ्रेगेंस होंगी, टेस्ट
होगा।
तो वो चीज आपको करनी पड़ेगी।
फिर जब आप खाओगे तो मजा भी आप ही को आएगा।
तो यू हैव टू क्रिएट नोट्स ऑन योर ओन।
चाहे मैं आपको दूं ना दूं खुद से क्रिएट
तो करना ही करना है। इट विल जस्ट बूस्ट
योर मेमोरी। मैं इस बात की गारंटी देता
हूं।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके। ओके। लेट्स अ मूव फॉरवर्ड।
ओके। ये नेटवर्क सेंट्रिक लॉग्स कौन जनरेट
करता है? यह पेरामीटर डिवाइसेस, नेटवर्क
अप्लायंसेस, मॉनिटरिंग ट्रैफिक बिटवीन
डिवाइसेस एंड फायर वाल्स जैसी डिवाइसेस जो
हैं यह जनरेट करती हैं। ठीक है? नेटवर्क
साइड क्लॉक एवरीवन फोकस हियर नाउ। इसके
सोर्सेस कहां-कहां से ये जनरेट हो के आती
है? तो नेक्स्ट जनरेशन फायर वाल जो होते
हैं जो कि आप जिसको लाइक एनजीएफW भी बोलते
हैं शॉर्ट में। नेक्स्ट जनरेशन फायर वॉल्स
आईडीएस या आईपीएस जो होते हैं वह होते हैं
जो इसको जनरेट करते हैं। वेब प्रॉक्सीस जो
होते हैं वह जनरेट करते हैं। जो नेट फ्लो
या आईपी फिक्स रिसीवर्स होते हैं जो कि
मैंने यहां पर आपको पहले बताया था जो डाटा
फ्लो को कंट्रोल करते हैं। डाटा फ्लो के
लिए यूज़ में आते हैं वो आपको जनरेट करते
हैं। वीpए गेटवेज जो होते हैं जो वीpएं
होते हैं वो आपको जनरेट करते हैं। ये क्या
रिवील करते हैं? तो सोर्स का आईपी कहां से
यह ट्रैफिक आ रहा है? डेस्टिनेशन आईपी
कहां को यह ट्रैफिक जा रहा है? किस पोर्ट
से ये ट्रैफिक आ रहा है? किस पोर्ट पे ये
ट्रैफिक जा रहा है? प्रोटोकॉल्स कौन कौन
सी प्रोटोकॉल यूज़ कर रहा है? है टीसीपी
यूडीपी आईसीएमपी कनेक्शन का स्टेट
स्टेटलेस है या स्टेटफुल है कनेक्शन क्या
है वह बताता है आपका एक्शन टेकन या मतलब
कि अलाऊ
है डिनाइड है या ड्रॉप ड्रॉप करना है अलऊ
करना है डिनाई ये सब चीजें आपको यह बताता
है नेटवर्क सेंट्रिक लॉक्स ठीक है अलाउड
है डिनाइड है क्या है टीचिंग एनालॉगी की
हम बात करें यहां पे तो नेटवर्क लॉक्स
टेल्स यू हु एंटर्ड एंड एग्जिटेड द
बिल्डिंग एंड व्हिच कॉरिडोर बस दे वॉक
थ्रू। यह आपका बताता है नेट ओ क्लॉक कि
भैया कौन घुसा था एंड कौन बाहर निकला और
किस रास्ते से वो निकला या घुसा। यह आपका
नेटवर्क क्लॉक बताता है। तो फोर्थ
सेंट्रिक क्लॉक्स बताते हैं कि एक रूम के
अंदर हुआ क्या था। ठीक है? एक रूम के अंदर
कोई वारदात हुई है उसके बारे में। नेटवर्क
सेंट्रिक क्लॉक जो होते हैं, वह बताते हैं
कि भाई कौन आया था? कौन गया है और किस
रास्ते से गया है।
बस ये चीज है। नेटवर्क क्लॉक सीसीटीवी गेट
हां सीसीटीवी ऑफ गेट। सीसीटीवी गेट का
सीसीटीवी है। सही बात है।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] सही बात है।
[हंसी]
अरे हां यार लाइक ठोका नहीं क्या लोगों
ने? लाइक लाइक ठोक दिया सबने। चलो लाइक तो
ठोक ही देते हो तुम लोग। अच्छी बात है।
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़] यहां
पे देखिए। अब मैं आपको एक चीज और बताता
हूं। हमारे एसओसी सीरीज गाइस
फाइव टू सिक्स क्लासेस और बचे हैं बस। एंड
देन यह सीरीज एंड हो जाएगी। आपकी एक लंबी
जर्नी हमारी एंड हो जाएगी। एंड आई एम वेरी
मच ग्लैड कि
इतने
टाइम तक अभी भी लगभग 50 लोग तो हमसे जुड़े
ही रहते हैं। हर सेशंस में, हर क्लासेस
में। 50 लोग कम से कम रहते हैं। एवरेज मैं
बात करूं। तो वो 50 लोगों के लिए मैं
बोलना चाहूंगा हैट्स ऑफ टू यू गाइस कि
आपने अभी तक इस चीज को कंटिन्यू रखा है।
एंड डेफिनेटली यू आर वेरी मच इंटरेस्टेड
एंड एंथूजियास्टिक अबाउट एसओसी और मेकिंग
करियर इन साइबर सिक्योरिटी और एंटरिंग इन
साइबर सिक्योरिटी थ्रू एसओसी वो आपके लिए
हेल्पफुल रहेगी। आई होप आई विश कि आप
अच्छा करें इस सीरीज के बाद इस इस साइबर
सिक्योरिटी के डोमेन में जर्नी में आपके
लाइफ में अच्छा हो एंड आप इसमें करियर
बनाओ। ठीक है? क्योंकि आज जब सॉफ्टवेयर
डेवलपमेंट और लाइक सॉफ्टवेयर इंजीनियरिंग
हो गई इन चीजों में सब ज्यादा घुसते हैं
लोग लाइक डेवलपमेंट और इन सब चीजों में
वहां पे सिक्योरिटी में अगर आप जा रहे हैं
तो इट्स अ वेरी गुड थिंग एंड इट्स अ वेरी
गुड इट्स अ वेरी बिग थिंग आई आई वुड से
एंड अगर आप थोड़ा सा टाइम देते हैं इस
डोमेन में तो आपका अच्छा जो है आपको
रिजल्ट मिलने वाला है। आपके करियर में
अच्छा टर्न आएंगे। अच्छे टर्न्स आएंगे
आपके करियर में। आपका करियर अच्छा होगा।
आपको थोड़ा पेशेंस रखना पड़ेगा। थोड़ा
टाइम देना पड़ेगा। ठीक? ठीक है? तो इट्स
ऑल इन योर हैंड्स। राइट?
ओके। [अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
थैंक यू वेरी मच। सर, विल आई हैव टू गिव
एन ऐप्टीट्यूड टेस्ट बिफोर द एसोसिएट
इंटरव्यू? इफ यू वांट यू कैन नो इशूज़।
यू आर वेलकम जगतगुरु स्वामी जी ओके सो की
टेक अवे फॉर स्टूडेंट्स अगर हम की टेक अवे
की बात मैं करूं तो क्या है यह ऑलवेज
कोरिलेट होस्ट लॉग्स विद नेटवर्क लॉक्स एक
एक अच्छे एसओसी एल1 एनालिस्ट का एक बहुत
ही अच्छा
बहुत बहुत ही अच्छा एक उनकी हैबिट यह होती
है जो उनको रखना चाहिए कि जो होस्ट
सेंट्रिक लॉग्स हैं
उनको नेटवर्क सेंट्रिक लॉक्स के साथ रिलेट
करना चाहिए हमेशा। इफ अ फायर लॉग शोज़
आउटबाउंड ट्रैफिक टू अ सस्िशियस आईपी ऑन
पोर्ट 444 टेट्रा 4 या क्वड 4 चेक द होस्ट
लॉग्स टू आइडेंटिफाई द एग्जैक्ट प्रोसेस
एग्जीक्यूटेबल मेकिंग दैट कनेक्शन। तो अगर
आपको नेटवर्क लॉग में फायर लॉक के अंदर
में कोई एक बाहर की तरफ जाती हुई आउटबाउंड
ट्रैफिक दिख रही है जो कि एक सस्िशियस
आईपी जो है ना
उस पे ट्रैफिक को सेंड कर रही है एक पोर्ट
नंबर 444 पे तो आपको होस्ट लॉक्स भी चेक
करनी चाहिए और आपको देखना चाहिए कि कौन सा
वह प्रोसेस है
कौन सा वह प्रोसेस है जो इस कनेक्शन के
लिए रिस्पांसिबल है जो इस कनेक्शन को
इस्टैब्लिश कर रहा है। किस प्रोसेस के
थ्रू ये कनेक्शन इस्टैब्लिश हो रही है और
एक मलेशियस आईपी को पर्टिकुलर पोर्ट नंबर
पे ट्रैफिक को भेजा जा रहा है या कोई डेटा
भेजी जा रही है। तो यू हैव टू कोरिलेट
होस्ट लॉग विथ नेटवर्क सेंट्रिक लॉक्स। जब
आप कोरिलेट करके जब आप इन्वेस्टिगेट करोगे
एज एन एसोसियल वन तो जो रिजल्ट आपके पास
आएगा वो माइंड ब्लोइंग रिजल्ट होगा। एंड
आप किसी चीज में चूकोगे नहीं। आपको मजा
आएगा। आपको लगेगा कि हां आपने एग्जैक्ट
प्रॉब्लम फाइंड कर ली है एंड आपने रॉल्व
कर दिया उस प्रॉब्लम को। दैट्स द मेन
थिंग। [अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
ओके? [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
अब यहां पे हम एक अटैक
पैटर्न को समझ लेते हैं जो हैकर्स जो है
यूज़ करते हैं टू अटैक एनी नेटवर्क। यही
पैटर्न सिर्फ यूज़ में लिया जाता है। जनरली
इसी में सब कुछ होता है। तो इस अटैक
पैटर्न को समझिएगा और इसी अटैक पैटर्न के
अकॉर्डिंग आप इन्वेस्टिगेशन भी कर सकते
हैं। जैसे कोई अटैक होती है तो आप सबसे
पहले इन्वेस्टिगेशन करेंगे रिक्निसेंस के
बारे में। देन आप रूट फ़ोर्स पासवर्ड
स्प्रेइंग के बारे में, कमांड एंड कंट्रोल
के बारे में, देन एक्सफिल्ट्रेशन के बारे
में। ये एक स्टेप आपको फॉलो करना है। ये
स्टेप जब आप फॉलो कर लेंगे तो आपका जो है
मान के चलो कि अ इन्वेस्टिगेशन बेस्ट ऑफ द
बेस्ट कहलाएगा। तो डिफेंडर्स मस्ट
रिकॉग्नाइज द कॉमन फसेस ऑफ अ नेटवर्क
इंट्रोजन एट द पैरामीटर। यह कॉमन फसेस है
नेटवर्क इंट्रोजन करने का कॉमन फज़। तो
सबसे पहला होता है रिकॉग्निसेंस एंड पोर्ट
स्कैनिंग। इंडिकेटर उसके लिए क्या-क्या
क्या इंडिकेटर हो सकते हैं? अ सिंगल
एक्सटर्नल आईपी प्रोबिंग 100्स ऑफ
सीक्वेंशियल पोर्ट्स ऑन एन इंटरनल पब्लिक
आईपी ओवर अ शॉर्ट ड्यूरेशन। अब कोई एक
बाहर की आईपी है [गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
वो आपके नेटवर्क के ऊपर बहुत सारे पोर्ट्स
को स्कैन कर रही है। तो इट्स अ चांस कि
देयर इज़ रिकॉग्नोसेंस हैपनिंग एंड पोर्ट
स्कैनिंग के थ्रू इनेशन गैदरिंग हो रही
है। इसका यह इंडिकेटर है। ब्रूट फ़ोर्स एंड
पासवर्ड स्प्रिंग इसका इंडिकेटर क्या है?
हाई वॉल्यूम ऑफ डिनाई और फेल्ड लॉग इन
लॉग्स। बहुत सारे ऐसे लॉग इन लॉग्स आपको
देखने को मिल रहे हैं। ऑथेंटिक मतलब लॉग
इन ऑथेंटिकेशन लॉग्स देखने को मिल रहे
हैं। जहां पर बहुत सारे डिनाई फेलियर वाले
लॉग्स हैं जो कि आपके एसएसएच पोर्ट 22 को
टारगेट किया जा रहा है। रिमोट डेस्कटॉप
प्रोटोकॉल आरडीपी पोर्ट 3389 को टारगेट
किया जा रहा है या वीपीए एंड पॉइंट्स को
टारगेट किया जा रहा है। तो आप समझिए कि
कोई ना कोई ब्रूड फ़ोर्स करने की कोशिश कर
रहा है और उस नेटवर्क में घुसने की कोशिश
कर रहा है। एसएसएच के थ्रू आरडीपी के थ्रू
वीपीए के अकाउंट्स को कॉम्प्रोमाइज करके
एंड अंदर आने की कोशिश कर रहा है। कमांड
एंड कंट्रोल बेकनिंग बेकनिंग बोलो या
बीकॉनिंग बोलो अलग-अलग इसके प्रोनाउंसिएशन
है। लोग बोलते हैं। सो मैं यहां पे
बेकनिंग बोलता हूं। कमांड एंड कंट्रोल C
टू बेकनिंग की अगर हम बात करें तो यहां पे
इंडिकेटर क्या होते हैं? पीरियडिक
आउटबाउंड कनेक्शन अटेमप्ट्स ऑन नॉन
स्टैंडर्ड पोर्ट्स और ओवर एचटीटीपी
एसटीपीएस टू ऑब्सक्योर एक्सटर्नल डोमेनस।
अब यहां पे कोई एक बाहर की तरफ ट्रैफिक जा
रही है। बाहर के नेटवर्क से कोई ट्रैफिक
बाहर के नेटवर्क से कोई कनेक्शन बनाई जा
रही है। नॉन स्टैंडर्ड पोर्ट्स पे
स्टैंडर्ड पोर्ट्स पे नहीं ऐसे वियर्ड
रैंडम पोर्ट्स पे जो जनरली यूज़ में नहीं
लिए जाते हैं। जो जनरली आपको पता भी नहीं
होंगे। मान लो कि कोई एक पोर्ट नंबर है
अब ये 33134 पोर्ट अब ये पोर्ट नंबर के
बारे में आपको नहीं पता है तो एक रैंडम
नॉन स्टैंडर्ड पोर्ट पे अगर कोई इस तरह के
कनेक्शन अटेमप्ट्स किए जा रहे हैं या फिर
एचटीटीपी एसटीपीएस के ऊपर ऐसे कनेक्शन
बनाया जा रहा है ताकि जो एक्सटर्नल डोमेन
है उनको ऑब्स सिक्योर किया जा सके ऐसा
उनको मतलब थोड़ा सा हाइड किया जा सके उनको
ऐसा लगा है कि अरे यार यह तो जेन्युइन हो
सकती है एसटीडीपीएस के ऊपर बात काम कर रहा
है ऐसा कुछ तो ऐसी चीजें जब हो ऐसी जब
कनेक्शंस बने तो समझ जाइए कि यहां पे वह
कनेक्शन एक कमांड कंट्रोल सर्वर से बनाई
जा रही है या बनाई जा सकती है। एंड वो एक
अटैकर कंट्रोलोल्ड सर्वर होता है। अटैकर
उसको कंट्रोल करके रखता है एंड वहां डेटा
भेजे जाते हैं। ये सारी चीजें। ठीक है?
उसके बाद होती है लास्ट में एक्स
फिल्ट्रेशन यानी कि अनयुअल हाई आउटगोन
ट्रैफिक वॉल्यूम सेंट फ्रॉम एन इंटरनल
डेटाबेस और फाइल सर्वर टू एन नोन
एक्सटर्नल आईपी। यानी कि आपके नेटवर्क से
डेटा को भेजा जा रहा है। बाहर। डेटा को
सेंसिटिव इनफो को चुराया गया है। सेंसिटिव
इनफो को गैदर कर लिया गया है। और बाहर की
तरफ एक बाहर के सर्वर पे जो कि अटैकर
कंट्रोल सर्वर है वहां भेजा जा रहा है।
बहुत सारे डेटा चुराए जा रहे हैं। उसको हम
एक्सफिल्ट्रेशन बोलते हैं। सो दीज़ आर द
की पैरामीटर थ्रेट्स एंड अटैक पैटर्न्स
दैट आर बीइंग यूज्ड टू इनफिल्ट्रेट अ
नेटवर्क और टू डू नेटवर्क इंट्रजंस।
नेटवर्क इंट्रोजनस करने के लिए, नेटवर्क
के अंदर घुसने के लिए, नेटवर्क के अंदर
अटैक करने के लिए यह अटैक पैटर्न्स यूज़
किए जाते हैं। इन अटैक पैटर्न्स को आप समझ
जाइए और इसी के अकॉर्डिंग आप अपनी
इन्वेस्टिगेशन भी करेंगे एज एन एसओसी एल
वन। दैट्स इट। ये तो पूरी चीजें थी जो
आपको मैंने अभी यहां पे समझाई। जहां पे
हमने एक नेटवर्क क्या होता है? किन
कॉम्पोनेंट से बना है? वहां से शुरू करा।
एसेट टाइप्स उनके रोल्स, सिक्योरिटी रिस्क
और मॉनिटरिंग प्रायोरिटीज़ को देखा।
नेटवर्क विज़िबिलिटी के अंदर होस्ट
सेंट्रिक और नेटवर्क सेंट्रिक लॉक्स के
बारे में जाना। और की पैरामीटर पैरामीटर
थ्रेट्स और अटैक पैटर्न्स क्या यूज किए
किए जाते हैं अटैकर्स की तरफ से नेटवर्क
एंड्रोजन के लिए ये सारी चीजें देखिए। ये
कहानी तो हो गई हमारे कांसेप्ट्स की बात।
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़] यहां
पे होता है कांसेप्ट हमारा खत्म। अब हम
आगे की तरफ बढ़ते हैं थोड़े डेमोंस्ट्रेशन
प्रैक्टिकल डेमोंस्ट्रेशन की तरफ। इसके
लिए हम यूज़ करेंगे ट्राईकमी का नेटवर्क
सिक्योरिटी एसेंशियल लैब को। एंड यहां पे
इनके भी बहुत सारे थ्योरी है। हम थ्योरी
पे नहीं जाने वाले हैं। हमने वो कवर
ऑलमोस्ट कर लिया। इनके भी थ्योरी में वो
सारी चीजें आपको मिल जाएंगी। लाइक आप
देखेंगे यहां पे फाइल सर्वर, डेटाबेस
एप्लीकेशन सर्वर आप इनको पढ़ सकते हैं।
फ्री लैब है, फ्री रूम है। यू कैन गो अहेड
एंड यू कैन रीड ऑन योर ओन। बिल्कुल पैसा
आपको नहीं देना है इसका फ्री है। तो आप
इनको पढ़ लीजिए। ठीक है? यहां पे मैं एक
लैब स्टार्ट करूंगा। स्टार्ट लैब मशीन और
इनके जो डेमोंस्ट्रेशन है उनको थोड़ा सा
देखने की हम कोशिश करेंगे कि व्हाट
एक्साक्टली दैट होल्स। व्हाट इग्ज़ैक्टली
दैट इज। ठीक है? तो मैं इसको क्लोज कर
देता हूं। यहां पे लैब मशीन ऑन हो रहा है।
इसको ऑन होने देते हैं। देन वी विल गो
अहेड। एंड यहां पे देखेंगे कि यहां पे ऑल
फाइल्स रिक्वायर्ड जो है वो पेरीमीटर
लॉग्स नाम के फोल्डर के अंदर में है। ठीक
है? बढ़िया है। यहां पे हमारे पास ये सारी
चीजें नेटवर्क पैरामीटर के बारे में बताया
गया है। बस पैरामीटर क्या होते हैं? हां।
इसमें एक टॉपिक है। मैं आपको बता देता
हूं। उसको जरूर पढ़ लीजिएगा। एक्सप्लोर
कीजिएगा। सभी लोग एक्सप्लोर कीजिएगा। इट्स
अ रिक्वेस्ट टू एवरीबॉडी। डीएमजी
डीमिलिटलाइज ज़ोन। ठीक है? जो
डीमिलिटराइज्ड ज़ोन होते हैं, यह पब्लिक
फेसिंग सर्विसेस को होस्ट करते हैं।
बेसिकली यह काफी इंटरेस्टिंग एक टॉपिक है
जो आप जानना चाहेंगे जिसके बारे में पढ़ना
चाहेंगे जो डीमिलिटराइज्ड ज़ोन कहलाते हैं।
डीएमजी ठीक है? ये कहलाते हैं। अब यहां पे
डीमिलिटराइज्ड ज़ोन जो है इसके बारे में
थोड़ा सा आप एक्सप्लोर कर लीजिएगा। यह
बेसिकली अभी वैसे मैं बताऊं तो अ बफर
नेटवर्क सेगमेंट वेयर पब्लिक फेसिंग
सर्वर्स आर प्लेस जैसे कि वेब सर्वर्स या
मेल सर्वर्स या वीपीएंस वगैरह हो गए। यह
सब डिमिलिटराइज्ड ज़ोन जो है उसमें ही होते
हैं। प्लेस किए जाते हैं। एंड दिस इज़ अ
वेरीेंट कांसेप्ट। तो आपको इसके बारे में
थोड़ा सा एक्सप्लोर करना है। थोड़ा जानकारी
ले लीजिएगा। मैं ये नहीं बोल रहा हूं कि
इसके बिना आप कुछ नहीं कर पाएंगे। बट
स्टिल प्लीज हैव अ लुक एट दिस टॉपिक। बाकी
चीजें मैंने आपको ऐसे कुछ खास है नहीं।
एक्सप्लेन करी हुई है। यहां पे दो चीजें
हैं जो लैब्स है उनको हम थोड़ा देखेंगे।
[हंसी]
नेटवर्क पैरामीटर्स की मॉनिटरिंग एंड
प्रोटेक्टिंग करने की हम बात करेंगे। पहले
चलिए तो मॉनिटरिंग द पैरामीटर आ जाते हैं।
इफ इट इज़ स्टार्टेड लेट्स सी।
अ आई थिंक स्टार्टेड। हां ये स्टार्ट हो
चुकी है। गुड।
ये हमारा स्टार्ट हो चुका है। ओके गुड। अब
देखिए मॉनिटरिंग द पैरामीटर की हम बात
करते हैं। पैरामीटर को मॉनिटरिंग करने की
बात करते हैं। तो अब इसमें कैसे क्या करना
है वो हम देखते हैं। ठीक है? मॉनिटरिंग द
पैरामीटर मींस यूजिंग फायर वाल्स इंट्रोसन
डिटेक्शन सिस्टम या आईडीएस या आईपीएस एंड
एक्सेस कंट्रोल टू एग्जामिन एंड लिमिट
एक्सपोज़र एंड इनफोर्स सिक्योरिटी रूल्स।
एक्सपोज़र को लिमिट करना। सिक्योरिटी रूल्स
को एक्स इनफोर्स करना। किन चीजों का यूज़
करके? आईडीएस इंट्रोस एंड डिटेक्शन सिस्टम
या आईपीएस इन सब का यूज़ करके। यह आपका
होता है। पेरीमीटर को मॉनिटर करना। ठीक
है? बस।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
एक सेकंड जस्ट जस्ट सेकंड गाइस।
जस्ट सेकंड गाइस।
जस्ट सेकंड जस्ट गिव मी वन मिनट
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
हम
ओके। चलिए इस क्लास के लास्ट में मैं आपसे
आपके क्वेश्चंस भी लूंगा। डोंट वरी।
क्वेश्चंस भी मैं लूंगा। ओके।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
अब मॉनिटर करने के लिए सिंपल आईडीएस
आईपीएस का यूज़ तो हम करेंगे आईडीएस का।
और एक्सेस कंट्रोल को इनफोर्स करने के
लिए, एक्सपोज़र को लिमिट करने के लिए,
सिक्योरिटी रूल्स को इनफोर्स करने के लिए।
ठीक है? दिस अलाउज़ द सिक्योरिटी एनालिस्ट
टू स्पॉट अर्ली स्टेज अटैक्स।
जब आप पैरामीटर को मॉनिटर करेंगे, जब आप
बाउंड्री को मॉनिटर अपने घर की सुरक्षा
करेंगे, आप अपने घर की रखवाली जब शुरू
करेंगे, तो ऑब्वियस सी बात है आप अपने घर
को सेफ रखेंगे। राइट? तो इस तरीके से
नेटवर्क को भी सेफ रखा जा सकता है। तो
अर्ली स्टेज अटैक्स जो अर्ली स्टेज अटैक्स
हैं उनसे बचाया जा सकता है। नेटवर्क को
ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक्स इन सब चीजों से बचाया
जा सकता है। मिस कॉन्फ़िगरेशन को डिटेक्ट
किया जा सकता है। किसी तरह का उम् अह
नेटवर्क के अंदर मिस कॉन्फ़िगरेशन है। उसको
यहां पे क्या किया जा सकता है? डिटेक्ट
किया जा सकता है। सेंसिटिव सर्विसेस को
एक्सपोज़ होने से बचाया जा सकता है। एंड
आउटबाउंड ट्रैफिक एनोमलीज़ अगर कोई बाहर की
तरफ ट्रैफिक जा रही है, उसमें कोई गड़बड़ लग
रही है तो उसको मॉनिटर किया जा सकता है।
एंड
लाइक डाटा कोई चुराई जा रही है,
एक्सपिल्ट्रेट की जा रही है तो उसको बचा
या उससे सेफगार्ड किया जा सकता है। ठीक
है? सब कुछ होंगी। सब कुछ होंगी अभी अभी
देखते जाइए आप लोग आप लोग क्लासेस देखिए
वी विल वी विल वी विल आल्सो सेट अप द लैब
डोंट वरी अबाउट दैट हम ये भी जानेंगे
लास्ट में कि हम अपना खुद का एक लैब कैसे
सेटअप वो बहुत ही नॉर्मल सा चीज है बहुत
छोटी सी चीज है लैब सेटअप करना इज़ नॉट अ
बिग थिंग इन एसओसी मैं आपको वो पूरा लैब
सेटअप भी बताऊंगा उसके पहले ही मैंने आपको
स्प्लंक का पूरा एक स्प्लंक की पूरी
ओवरव्यू क्लास दे दे दिया है तो लैब ऐप
सेटअप के बाद आपको स्प्ल यूज़ करना है। एज
सिंपल एज दैट। एक कोई टूल पकड़ लो, मास्टर
कर लो। उसी तरीके का हर टूल होता है। जो
भी एसओसी के लिए जो टूल्स यूज़ होते हैं
एसआईएम टूल्स वो सब ऑलमोस्ट सिमिलर तरीके
से काम करते हैं। थोड़ी बहुत डिफरेंसेस
होती हैं उनके लुक एंड फील में। एक टूल पे
आपने मास्टर कर लिया। सब आपको यूज़ करना आ
जाएगा। सब सारे टूल्स। बस इतना ही पता है।
तो Splunk के बारे में मैंने आपको ऑलरेडी
बताया हुआ है। बस सेटअप करना जो है वो मैं
आपको जरूर बताऊंगा। उसके लिए बेफिक्र
रहिए। लास्ट में हम उसको देखेंगे। उतना
इंपॉर्टेंट नहीं। मैं मानता हूं उस चीज
को। वो कोई भी YouTube वीडियो देख के
सेटअप कर सकता है। बट स्टिल आई वुड ब्रिंग
दैट इन द क्लास। डेफिनेटली उसके लिए
बेफिक्र रहिए। ठीक है?
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
चलिए अब यहां पे मॉनिटरिंग पैरामीटर इन
एक्शन देखते हैं। अब सबसे पहले क्या होता
है? प्रोबिंग फॉर पोर्ट्स। तो पोर्ट स्कैन
हम करते हैं। अब जैसे इनमें एक यहां पे दी
हुई है। यहां पे एक
फोल्डर दी हुई है। ठीक है? फोल्डर
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] को जब हम ओपन
करेंगे तो यहां पर दो सॉरी सॉरी यहां पर
पेरामीटर लॉक्स के अंदर में दो फोल्डर्स
हैं। टास्क सिक्स और एक चैलेंज। तो टास्क
सिक्स जो है इसके लिए है। तो टास्क सिक्स
के अंदर जाएंगे तो तीन यहां पे फाइल्स
हैं। फायरवल लॉक्स, वीपीए लॉक्स, वेप
लॉक्स। ठीक है? तो यहां पे प्रोबिंग फॉर
पोर्ट्स। पोर्ट स्कैनिंग। तो अब ये बोला
है एन अटैकर इज़ टेस्टिंग योर नेटवर्क टू
सी व्हिच पोर्ट्स आर ओपन और क्लोज व्हाइल
द फायरवल इज़ डूइंग इट्स जॉब एंड ब्लॉकिंग
देम। तो फायर लॉक्स के अंदर हमें देखने को
मिलेगा क्या-क्या। मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं
यहां पे। FW लॉक्स को जब हम ओपन करेंगे
तो कुछ इस तरीके की चीजें आपको देखने को
कहां गया भाई फेरोलॉग
हां
कुछ इस तरीके की लॉग आपको देखने को मिल
जाती है फेरोल लॉक के अंदर में जहां पे
आपको दिखेगा कि लाइक अह किस आईपी से
रिक्वेस्ट आई है किस आईपी एंड एंड किस
पोर्ट पे ये जा रही है, टारगेट कर रही है।
उसका एक्शन का रिजल्ट क्या है? अलऊ हुआ है
या ब्लॉक हुआ है। ये सारी चीज़ आपको यहां
पे देखने को लॉक के अंदर मिलेगी। राइट? तो
फायरवल लॉक्स के अंदर में क्या होता है?
फायरवल इसी तरीके से काम करता है। कुछ
मशियस जो रिक्वेस्ट होंगी उनको ब्लॉक
करेगा। नॉर्मल रिक्वेस्ट्स को ये अलऊ कर
देगा। ठीक है? उस तरीके से काम करती है।
दूसरा सिनेरियो होता है अटैकिंग द वेब
सर्वर। वेब सर्वर को अटैक करना। तो अब
जैसे मान लो एक वेफ लॉग्स है तो हम वेफ
लॉक्स की बात करें अगर
तो इससे पता चलता है वेब सर्वर पे अब जैसे
मान लो यहां पे आपको दिख रहा होगा ये
लॉग्स है तो यहां पे आपको टाइम स्टैंप पता
चल जाता है कि सोर्स आईपी क्या थी कहां से
ये जनरेट हो रही है आपका जो रिक्वेस्ट है
ये कहां से आ रही है एक्शन क्या है इसको
अलऊ किया गया है रिक्वेस्ट क्या किया गया
है तो गेट रिक्वेस्ट है एक और इस पेज को
रिक्वेस्ट की गई है इंडेक्स को तो इससे
पता चलता है कि कौन सा पेज एक्सेस किया जा
रहा है कौन से पेज को अब यहां पे आप देख
सकते हैं कि यहां से एक सोर्स आईपी है
यहां से रिक्वेस्ट की गई है। इस आईपी से
एक्शन इसको ब्लॉक किया गया है। ब्लॉक
क्यों किया गया है? क्योंकि रिक्वेस्ट में
गेट रिक्वेस्ट में एक सर्च क्वरी जो है वह
एक स्क्रिप्ट को पाई गई है। एक स्क्रिप्ट
अलर्ट एक्सेस स्क्रिप्ट ऐसा एक स्क्रिप्ट
अटैक टाइप यहां पे क्या दिख रहा है?
एक्सेस। तो यहां पे एक स्क्रिप्ट का यूज़
किया गया है जो कि एक्सेसिस स्क्रिप्ट हो
सकती है। इसलिए यहां पे इसको फायरवॉल ने
ब्लॉक कर दिया है। क्योंकि freवॉल को लग
रहा है कि ये एक स्क्रिप्ट है। एक्सेसिस
पॉसिबल अटैक हो सकती है। तो इसको ब्लॉक
मारो। तो यहां पे इस ट्रैफिक को ब्लॉक कर
दिया है। तो ये एक आईडीएस का लॉग है। वेफ
लॉग है। सॉरी यहां पे इसी तरीके से और भी
लॉग्स हैं जिसमें कि आपको डिफरेंट चीजें
और देखने को मिलेंगी। जैसे आप देखो यहां
पे एक यहां पे ब्लॉक हुई है इस आईपी से।
क्यों ब्लॉक हुई है? क्योंकि यहां पे गेट
रिक्वेस्ट आ रही है। जहां पे आप देख सकते
हैं यह एक डायरेक्टरी ट्रेवर्सल का पेलोड
है जो कि यूज़ में लिया गया है। डायरेक्टरी
ट्रेवर्सल जहां से ईटीसी पास डब्ल्यूडी के
कंटेंट को फेच करने की कोशिश की जा रही
है। अगर फर फच हो जाएगी तो ये डायरेक्टरी
ट्रेवर्सल वलेबिलिटी यहां पे पॉसिबल है।
तो ये भी एक अटैक है जिसको कि ब्लॉक कर
दिया गया है। राइट? इसी तरीके से इन लॉ्स
में आप देखेंगे तो बाकी जो अलाउड हैं बाकी
सारे लॉग जो नॉर्मल पेजेस को एक्सेस करने
की कोशिश कर रहे हैं। कॉन्टैक्ट पीएp
इंडेक्स. जो वेबसाइट की नॉर्मल वेब पेजेस
हैं उनको जब एक्सेस करने की कोशिश की जा
रही है तो उनको अलाउ किया जा रहा है। जहां
कुछ गड़बड़ हो रही है वहां पे ब्लॉक कर
दिया जा रहा है।
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
उसके बाद आते हैं गेसिंग द पासवर्ड्स। अब
वीpए लॉक्स की हम बात करें वीpए लॉक्स की
तो आप देखेंगे यहां पे कि यहां पे अ इस
आईपी से एक वीpए लॉगिन का एक्सेस ट्राई
किया जा रहा है। ठीक है ना? इस आई इस टाइम
स्टैंप पे इस आईपी से किस पे इस आईपी पे
किया जा रहा है। यूजर भैया यहां पे आपको
देख सकते हैं कि सक्सेस ऑथेंटिकेशन सक्सेस
है यहां पे। यहां पे सक्सेस हो जा रही है।
यहां पे क्या है? यूजर बी ज़ों्स। यूजर इस
यूजर के लिए ट्राई किया जा रहा है। फिर
एडमिन यूजर के लिए ट्राई किया जा रहा है
तो फेल हो जा रही है। फिर एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर
के लिए भी ट्राई किया जा रहा है। यह भी
फेल हो जा रही है। फिर एक नॉर्मल यूजर के
लिए एस स्मिथ किया जाए तो सक्सेस हो जा
रहा है। रूट के लिए जब ट्राई कर रहा है तो
फेल हो जा रही है। यहां पे टेस्ट में फेल
हो जा रही है। एम डोए में सक्सेस हो जा
रही है। तो ये अलग-अलग यूज़र्स के लिए वी
जो वीpएं कनेक्शन बनाने की कोशिश की जा
रही है अलग-अलग यूज़र्स के लिए। किसी में
फेल हो रही है, किसी में ये सक्सेस हो जा
रही है। तो इस तरीके से आप जो है ब्रूट
फ़ोर्स अटैक को भी देख सकते हैं कि भाई कौन
से अटैक में बेसिकली सक्सेस मिल रहा है।
कौन से अटैक्स को बार-बार परफॉर्म किया जा
रहा है। ये सारी चीजें इससे आपको पता चल
जाती है। तो इस तरह की चीजें होती है। अब
यहां पे हम क्वेश्चंस को थोड़ा इस लैब के
थ्रू आंसर करने की कोशिश करेंगे। लेट्स सी
कि इफ वी कैन आंसर ऑ नॉट राइट। हम देखते
हैं। एग्जाममिन द फायर लॉक्स। हमें फायर
लॉक्स को एग्जाम करना है। तो हम पहले FW
लॉक्स को ओपन करते हैं भैया। तो फायर
लॉक्स को ओपन करने के लिए मैं यहां पर
टर्मिनल ओपन कर लेता हूं। और यहां पर मैं
टर्मिनल को यूज़ करते हैं। ज्यादा मजा आएगा
टर्मिनल को यूज़ करेंगे तो। तो यहां पर आप
देख सकते हैं एलएस करेंगे तो Firewall log
ये सारी फाइल्स हैं। तो इसको एग्जामिन
करने के लिए मैं कैट Firewall logs ओपन कर
लेता हूं। कैट से पूरी लॉक ओपन हो जाएगी।
कुछ इस तरीके से आप देख सकते हैं यहां पे।
ये ओपन हो गई। राइट? अब देखते हैं। व्हिच
IPपी एड्रेस इज़ परफॉर्मिंग द पोर्ट स्कैन?
कौन सा IPपी एड्रेस पोर्ट को स्कैन कर रहा
है? तो भैया देखो यहां पे अब इन सारे
लॉग्स में फायर लॉग्स में कौन सा IPपी
एड्रेस पोर्ट को स्कैन कर रहा है तो आपको
यहां पे दिख रहा होगा जो IP एड्रेस है
जिससे कि स्कैनिंग की जा रही है ये देखो
व्हिच IPपी एड्रेस परफॉर्म अब ये तो आपका
यहां पे ब्लॉक हो रहा है ये देखो जितने भी
ब्लॉक वाले जो है पोर्ट स्कैनिंग कर रहे
हैं ब्लॉक वाले तो अगर आप देखेंगे तो
ब्लॉक वाली कौन-कौन सी कौन सी IPपी एड्रेस
है तो हम इसको निकालते हैं हम उसको ट्राई
करते हैं निकालने की तो मैं यहां पे क्या
करूंगा मैं यहां पे उम् कमांड लगा देते
हैं।
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
कैट Firew LGs एंड यहां पे मैं गैब करूंगा
और एक ब्लॉक कीवर्ड के लिए सर्च करूंगा कि
ब्लॉक के लिए कौन-कौन से हैं? तो ब्लॉक के
लिए ये सारी हैं। इन सब में IPपी एड्रेस
हमारा सेम है। यही इसी आईपी एड्रेस को
बार-बार ब्लॉक किया जा रहा है। ब्लॉक
क्यों किया जा रहा है? बिकॉज़ इट्स बीइंग
यूज्ड टू स्कैन। और जब ये मल्टीपल स्कैन्स
कर रहा है, बार-बार स्कैन कर रहा है, आप
देख सकते हैं कि ये एक ही आईपी है। एक ही
आईपी है। वो अलग-अलग पोर्ट्स पे स्कैन मार
रही है। यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं
परफॉर्मिंग द पोर्ट स्कैन। पोर्ट को स्कैन
किया जा रहा है। तो ये जो आईपी है
203013.10
यही रिक्वेस्ट भेज रही है। ये सोर्स आईपी
है। ये डेस्टिनेशन आईपी है। ये रिक्वेस्ट
भेज रही है स्कैनिंग का स्कैनिंग के लिए।
और किसको भेज रही है? इस IP पे 10.02.20
इस पे ये स्कैन मार रही है और इसके
अलग-अलग पोर्ट पे स्कैन मार रही है। देखो
IP सेम ही है सारे बट पोर्ट्स अलग-अलग
हैं। 21 22 23 25 53 80 110 135 139 443
445 44 33 336 3389 5980 ये सारे पोर्ट्स
पे स्कैन मारे। तो यह पोर्ट स्कैनिंग कौन
कर रहा है भैया हमारा? यही आईपी कर रहा
है। तो इस आईपी को पकड़ो। इसको कॉपी मारो
एंड यहां पे पेस्ट मारो। दैट्स इट। सिंपल
था। ठीक है? अब यहां आते हैं इन द वफ
लॉग्स। अब ये वफ लॉग पे आ गए। ठीक है
भैया। हम वेफ लॉग को अप करते हैं। कैट वेफ
लॉग कैट से आप देखते हैं वो कंटेंट्स ऑफ़ द
फाइल। व्हिच सिंगल सोर्स आईपी इज़
रिस्पांसिबल फॉर ऑल द ब्लॉक्ड वेब अटैक्स?
कौन सा ऐसा सोर्स आईपी है जो रिस्पांसिबल
है सारे ब्लॉक्ड वेब अटैक्स के लिए? तो
भैया ब्लॉक्ड वेब अटैक्स कौन-कौन से हैं
भाई? देखो तो ब्लॉक वाले भाई कौन-कौन से
हैं? तो इसमें देख रहे हो आप अलऊ ब्लॉक
अलऊ ब्लॉक ये सब आ रहा है। तो हम ब्लॉक
वाले को खाली ढूंढ लेते हैं। इतना कौन
टेंशन ले है ना? हम ब्लॉक वाले को ढूंढ
लेते हैं भाई। तो हम इसको कैट करते हैं और
फिर से किसमें था यार? वेफ में था। कौन
सा? वेफ लॉग में। वेफ वाली है। इसमें
ग्रेब करते हैं और ब्लॉक वाले जो है ना उन
सबको ढूंढते हैं। तो भैया ब्लॉक वाले
हमारे पास तीन रिक्वेस्ट इस पूरी फाइल के
अंदर में है। ठीक है? कैट का मतलब है
कंटेंट देखना। किसी भी फाइल का कंटेंट
देखना हो तो लinक्स के अंदर में कैट कमांड
का यूज़ में लिया जाता है। पाइप लाइन का
मतलब आप में से कई लोगों को पता भी होगा।
नहीं पता मैं बता देता हूं। उसके बाद एक
और कमांड दी। ये सेपरेट कमांड है। ग्रेप।
कैट इज़ अ डिफरेंट सेपरेट कमांड। ग्रेप इज़
अ सेपरेट कमांड। दो कमांड्स को हम एक साथ
मिक्स जब करके चलाते हैं तो ये पाइपलाइन
का यूज़ करते हैं। कब? जब पहले कमांड का
आउटपुट हमें दूसरे कमांड के लिए एज अ
इनपुट को यूज करना पड़े। एज अ इनपुट यूज
करना पड़े। तो ग्रेप का काम होता है एक
पर्टिकुलर कीवर्ड को ढूंढना। सिंपल अभी
समझो इतना ही कि ग्रेप का मतलब है जिस
कीवर्ड को आपको ढूंढना हो उसको वहां पे
ग्रेप के बाद वो कीवर्ड डाल देना। ठीक है?
अब कैट जब मैंने दिया तो इस टीx फाइल का
जो भी आउटपुट होगा वो इस पाइपलाइन की वजह
से इसका इनपुट बन जाएगा। यानी कि कैट वेब
मतलब कि इस वेब logtxt फाइल के अंदर के
सारे कंटेंट्स को दिखाओ। ठीक है? और जो भी
कंटेंट देख के आए हमारा वो एज अ इनपुट
जाएगा इसके अंदर। अब इसका मतलब हो गया कि
गैब करो उन सारे आउटपुट्स में से ब्लॉक
कीवर्ड वाले। तो जितने भी आउटपुट है उसमें
से ब्लॉक वाले हमें यहां पे देखने को मिल
गए हैं। एज सिंपल एज दैट। समझ में आ गई
होगी सबको? तो इसमें भाई कौन सा आईपी है?
सोर्स आईपी निकाला विद सिंगल सोर्स आईपी।
तो सोर्स आईपी हमारा यही तो है भाई। 198
151 यह रहा यह सोर्स आईपी हमारा दे दो यही
जिसमें ब्लॉक हो रहा है।
हो गई अब देखो इन द वीपीए लॉक्स हाउ मेनी
ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटेम्प्ट्स फेल्ड कितने ब्रूट
फ़ोर्स अटेम्प्ट्स फेल हुए हैं वीpए लॉक्स
में। तो चलिए इसको भी चेक कर लेते हैं।
वीpए लॉक्स पे चलते हैं। तो कैट वीपीए
लॉक्स
अब फेल्ड कितने हुए? तो अब देखो यहां पे
यहां पे भैया बहुत सारे फेल्ड ऑथ फेल्ड ऑथ
आ रहे हैं। तो चलो फेल्ड ऑथ वाले पहले
निकालते हैं हम फेल्ड ऑथ वाले फेल्ड करते
हैं पहले तो कैट वीपीए
कैट वीपीए लॉक किया। अब यहां पे गैब किया
अब हम यहां पे फेल्ड वाला निकालते हैं। तो
भैया फेल्ड वाले बहुत सारे हैं यहां पे।
अब इसको या तो अब इसको तुम या तो काउंट
करो एक-एक करके बैठ के जो कि इंपॉसिबल
मतलब पॉसिबल तो है बट बहुत मेहनत लगेगी
यार काउंट करते रहो। तो यहां पे एक सिंपल
सा कमांड है। ग्रेप किया, फेल्ड किया। अब
यहां पे एक और पाइप लाइन लगाएंगे। अब इसका
आउटपुट गैप वाले का इसके लिए इनपुट
डालेंगे कि भैया काउंट करो कितने थे ये।
तो इसके लिए डब्ल्यू सी वर्ड काउंट हम
यहां पे कमांड यूज़ करते हैं।
इसको लिस्ट करते हैं और
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] सॉरी और इसको
लिस्ट करते हैं और देखते हैं। तो यहां पे
हमने WC हफन एल का यूज़ किया। लिस्ट किया
हमें और यहां पे हमें नंबर मिला है 90।
यानी कि 90 फेल्ड अटेम्प्ट्स हैं। तो
हमारा आंसर 90 हो जाएगा। एज सिंपल।
[संगीत]
ठीक है? उसके बाद है हमारा क्वेश्चन। वि
सस्िशियस IP एड्रेस वाज़ फाउंड अटेमप्टिंग
द ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक अगेंस्ट द वीपीए
गेटवे। अब भैया वीपीए गेटवे तो ये वीpए
वाला ही है क्या? ये कौन सा है ये? हां
वीपीए लॉग ही है। तो अब हमें फिर से वीpए
लॉक चेक करना होगा एक बार।
ये रहा। अब ये आ रहा है व्हिच सस्िशियस
IPपी एड्रेस वाज़ फाउंड अटेमप्टिंग द ब्रूट
फ़ोर्स अटैक अगेंस्ट द वीपीए गेटवे। अब ये
कौन सा सस्िशियस IPपी एड्रेस था जो ब्रूट
फ़ोर्स अटैक करने की कोशिश कर रहा है? तो
भैया अब इसमें देखो ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक कौन
कर रहा है? ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक का मतलब क्या
हुआ कि बार-बार अलग-अलग अ
ट्राई करना
है ना यूज़र्स पे अलग-अलग मतलब बार-बार
पासवर्ड्स को ट्राई करना ऐसे होता है ऐसे
करके। तो अभी आप देखते हैं कौन सा आईपी है
भैया यहां पे जो इसके लिए रिस्पांसिबल है।
तो आप देख सकते हैं यहां पे अ जो फेल्ड
आईपीस फेल्ड हो रहे हैं। फेल्ड हो रहे हैं
यहां पे। आप देख रहे हो फेल्ड फेल्ड हो
रहा है। ऑब्वियसली यही ट्राई मार रहा है
बार-बार। फेल्ड वाला फेल्ड वाला देख रहे
हो बार-बार यूज़र्स टेस्ट के लिए रूट के
लिए एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर एडमिन के लिए ये ट्राई
मार रहा है।
ये बार-बार ट्राई मार रहा है जिसमें कि
इसको फेलियर मिल रहा है। ये अगेन यहां पे
फेल हुआ। आप यहां पे 45 137 वाला ये ये
वाला। तो ये आईपी जो है बार-बार फेल हो
रहा है और यह ट्राई मार रहा है। तो हमारा
यह आईपी जो है यही हमारा आंसर है।
दैट्स [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] इट।
गॉट इट। सो हमें मिल चुका है यहां पे। ठीक
है? तो ये हमारा डन सॉल्व हो गया। अब हम
आते हैं पेरामीटर लॉग्स इन्वेस्टिगेटिंग द
ब्रिज। पहले हमने क्या किया? मॉनिटरिंग और
प्रोटेक्टिंग का किया। अब हम यहां पे आ
रहे हैं कि पेरामीटर लॉग्स जो होते हैं
बाहर वाली जो लॉग्स हैं उसको इन्वेस्टिगेट
करेंगे। ठीक है?
और देखेंगे क्या एक्सक्टली हो रहा है। ठीक
है?
देखते हैं लेट्स सी। तो यहां पे है
इनी टेक corrp अ मिड साइज फाइनेंसियल
सर्विज कंपनी हैज़ रिसेंटली डिप्लॉयड अ
न्यू फायर वाल एंड इंट्रोसन डिस्ट्रक्शन
सिस्टम। एक आइडियास ऑफ़ फायर वाल इन्होंने
डिप्लॉय किया है टू मॉनिटर इट्स नेटवर्क
पैरामीटर। ओवर द पास्ट मंथ सिक्योरिटी
एनालिस्ट हैव नोटिस एबनॉर्मल ट्रैफिक
पैटर्न। कुछ महीनों से सिक्योरिटी
एनालिस्ट ने एब्नॉर्मल ट्रैफिक पैटर्न
नोटिस किया है। बट द एसओसी टीम हैज़ बीन
ओवरवेम्ड एंड मिस्ड डीपर एनालिसिस। ठीक
है? एसओसी एसओसी टीम थोड़ा सा दिमाग हिल
गया उनका और [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
डीप एनालिसिस मिस कर गए। एज अ सिक्योरिटी
एनालिस्ट यू हैव बीन टास्क विथ रिव्यूइंग
वन मंथ ऑफ़ पैरामीटर। एक महीने का पैरामीटर
लॉक देखना है आपको। टू डिटरमाइन व्हाट
टेक्निक्स द एडवर्सरी यूज़्ड एंड वेदर दे
सक्सीडेड। क्या उनको सक्सेस मिला है? यू
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] हैव बीन
गिवेन थ्री सेट्स ऑफ लॉग्स फ्रॉम द टाइम
ऑफ इंसिडेंट। आपको तीन लॉग्स मिले गए हैं
जो कि मिल जो कि कहां पे सिचुएटेड है?
आपके इस
फोल्डर के अंदर में पैरामीटर लॉक्स के
अंदर में कहां पे है? चैलेंजेस के अंदर।
ये चैलेंज वाला फोल्डर है। इसके अंदर में
है। तीन लॉग्स हैं। फायर लॉग, आईडीएस
अलर्ट्स लॉग्स, वीpए ऑथ लॉग्स। ठीक है?
तीनों है। अब इसको इन्वेस्टिगेट करना है।
तो इसमें दो तरीके के मेथड्स हैं। एक तो
आप मैनुअल लॉग एनालिसिस कर सकते हैं। जो
कि कमांड्स के थ्रू हेड कमांड या कैट
कमांड के थ्रू कर सकते हैं। मैनुअली आप
लॉग्स को एनालिसिस कीजिए। तीनों लॉग्स को
लाइक फायर लॉग को कीजिए। आईडीएस अलर्ट्स
को कीजिए, वीpए ऑथ लॉग्स को कीजिए। ठीक
है? ये कर सकते हैं। या तो आप ऑटोमेटिक अह
लाइक
दूसरा जो मेथड है मेथड टू वह क्या कर सकते
हैं? तो वो भी देख लेते हैं। स्प्लक के
थ्रू कर सकते हैं। तो इन्होंने स्प्लंक का
भी एक
इंस्टेंस जो है इस पर्टिकुलर लोकेशन पे
लोकल होस्ट 8000 ब्राउज़र में एक्सेस करके
आप इसको एक्सेस कर सकते हैं। इन्होंने
इसको होस्ट करके रखा है। तो स्प्लंक के
अंदर में भी आप इस तरह के कीवर्ड्स
इंडेक्स नेटवर्क लॉग्स को करके और यहां पे
आप सिंपली सर्च कर सकते हैं। देख सकते हैं
कि बेसिकली लॉग्स को आप इंस इन्वेस्टिगेट
कर सकते हैं। तो स्प्लंक वाली चीजें तो
हमने देखी हैं। हम यहां पे थोड़ा मैनुअली
भी देखेंगे क्योंकि मैनुअली भी करनी आपको
आनी चाहिए। मैनुअली करनी आएगी। आप हो सकता
है कोई काम स्प्लन के थ्रू ना करके आप
मैनुअली जल्दी कर लें और वो आपके लिए
ज्यादा इजी हो जाए। तो मैनुअली भी आना
चाहिए। तो हम मैनुअली भी करेंगे। तो यहां
पे मैं इन एग्जांपल्स पे इनके नहीं जाते।
इनके बहुत सारे एग्जांपल्स हैं। जैसे अब
फायरव जैसे अब इन्होंने क्या दिया है यहां
पे? सिंपल यहां पे कुछ भी नहीं है यार।
यहां पे अगर मान लो आपको फायर लॉक्स को
एनालिसिस करना है। तो हेड फायर लॉक्स। अब
देखो हेड कमांड जो होता है ना यह बेसिकली
क्या होता है? मैं आपको बता देता हूं। हेड
कमांड
टॉप की अ रिजल्ट्स दिखाता है एक फाइल के
अंदर की बाय डिफॉल्ट ये टॉप के 10
रिजल्ट्स दिखाता है अगर हेड ओनली फाइल नेम
लिख दीजिएगा तो वहीं अगर आपको किसी
स्पेसिफिक लाइन की देखनी है जैसे अ टॉप की
टू लाइंस थ्री लाइंस तो वहां पे आपको टू
थ्री मेंशन करना पड़ता है हेड के बाद यहां
पे अगर कुछ नहीं मेंशन है सीधा हेड फायर
लॉक तो टॉप की 10 लाइन जो है वो दिखा देगा
जो कि यहां पे भी आपको यहां पे दिख रहा
होगा 1 2 3 देख रहे हैं 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 ये भी 10 यहां पे लाइंस आपको दिखाए गए
हैं। इस तरीके से होती है। हेड की जगह आप
बेसिकली कैट कमांड का यूज़ कर सकते हो। कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं है। कैट कमांड इज़ आल्सो
यूज़्ड फॉर द व्यूविंग ऑफ द कंटेंट्स। तो
हम यहां पे सीधा आते हैं लैब पे
एंड लेट्स सी थोड़ा यहां पे मल्टीपल
क्वेश्चंस हैं। एग्जामिन द फेयर लॉक्स।
चलिए FW LX को एग्जामिन करते हैं। क्या
दिक्कत है? Far LX को एग्जामिन करना है तो
राइट क्लिक करके टर्मिनल ओपन करते हैं।
कैट फायर
ठीक है
हां डिफॉल्ट पर 10 लाइंस होती है कैट फायर
लॉक्स तो ये [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
फायर लॉक्स हैं जो आपको यहां पे दिख रहे
हैं इस तरीके के फायर दिख रहे हैं। ठीक
है? व्हाट एक्सटर्नल आईपी परफॉर्म द मोस्ट
रिकॉनसेंस? सबसे ज्यादा रिक्गोसेंस कौन से
एक्सटर्नल आईपी ने परफॉर्म किया है? तो आप
देख सकते हैं यहां पे कौन से एक्सटर्नल
आईपी ने सबसे ज्यादा रिकॉनसेंस वो करा है।
तो आप देखेंगे यहां पे एक्सटर्नल आईपी जो
है सबसे ज्यादा अब देखो एक IP है 2030
1113100
यह एक IP है आपकी। राइट? उसके बाद यहां पे
एक आईपी यह है। राइट? यह तो खैर इंटरनल
आईपीस है आपकी बट एक्सटर्नल IPपी में आपका
203 वाली है एक आईपी है आपका यहां पर एक
इंटरनल आईपी भी है 192 इसको हम वैसे भी
इग्नोर कर देंगे उसके बाद हमारे पास और भी
है क्या 2031 ये सेम ही आईपी है हम सेम
आईपी है आई थिंक
यहां पे एक 19251 ये आईपी है तो एक बार
देख लेते हैं मेन आईपीस हमारे पास ज्यादा
नहीं है। यह और यह दो आईपीस हैं। सो,
दोनों आईपीस का हम काउंटिंग कर सकते हैं।
अगर आपको लाइक ऐसा है कि आईपीस का
काउंटिंग करना है, तो आईपीस का वी कैन डू
काउंटिंग एंड वी कैन टेस्ट। तो, यह 10. यह
60 ये सब तो उतने कुछ खास नहीं है।
क्योंकि यह अभी शुरू है। यह 198,5100
वाली आईपी है। एक 203 यह वाली आईपी है।
एक। तो, हम ऐसे काउंट कर सकते हैं। वी कैन
काउंट इट, राइट? तो हम यहां पे कैट
अ उसके बाद यहां पे कैट कर लिया और
firewall है ना यह फायरवल
firewall l यहां पे कर दिया यहां पे हम
ग्रेब कर लेते हैं और यह आईपी देख लेते
हैं कौन सी आईपी है भैया पहला हम आईपी देख
लेते हैं 123 वाली देख लेते हैं
यह वाली आईपी देख लेते हैं
ठीक है 10 इसको मैं वैसे कर देता हूं
ठीक है? यह कर लेते हैं। एंड यहां पर WC
हफन L कर लेते हैं। इसको देख लेते हैं।
212 है यहां पे और एक 192 वाली देख लेते
हैं। 212 बार 198 वाली सॉरी
ये वाली 19 यही है ना? अ 5177
यही है ना? शायद 198 वाली
नहीं आई थिंक ये तो अलग-अलग है यार। बट
वैसे भी है बट मुझे वही ज्यादा लग रहा है
बट देख लेते हैं आईपी
हम हम हम
लेट्स काउंट दिस आई थिंक ये ज्यादा नहीं
होने चाहिए 300 बार है ओके ये 300 बार है
अ ये 300 बार है दिस इज़ दिस इज़ 300 सो ये
इससे भी ज्यादा है तो मुझे लगता है फिर तो
यही होंगे आई थिंक आई थिंक यही होगा
1777 वाला एक बार देख लेते हैं
नहीं नहीं
एक और देख लेते हैं। 192 वाली भी है क्या?
अ वन
10 वाली भी देख लेते हैं। लेट्स सी
10.0.6
यह देख लेते हैं एक बार।
हर चीज में गैब करोगे क्या?
हां ये भी है। आप ग्रैप करके वैसे भी
ब्लॉक से भी पता कर सकते हो। वैसे तो सेंस
में अगर ब्लॉक हुआ होगा तो है ना यही यही
बोल रहे हो ना? बट इसको देख लेते हैं। 314
है। तो आई थिंक 10 डॉट वाली तो इससे
ज्यादा ही होगी शायद। तो एक बार वो देख
लेते हैं। अलऊ अलऊ अलऊ अलऊ है ना ब्लॉक भी
है ना बहुत सारे तो रिकॉनसेंस करा
इन्होंने अ तो ब्लॉक वाला देख लेते हैं।
ब्लॉक वाली कितनी कितनी है वो भी देख के
एक बार चेक कर लेते हैं। सही बोला कि
ब्लॉक वाली एक बार चेक कर लेते हैं। गैब
कीवर्ड ब्लॉक
है ना? तो इसमें
यह सारी ब्लॉक है। तो
यह सारी ब्लॉक हैं। तो ब्लॉक में मुझे
लगता है सबसे ज्यादा एक तो हमारी 203 यह
वाली आईपी है। एक तो हमारी यह वाली आईपी
है। 45 वाली एक है हमारी। तो ओके। सबसे
ज्यादा हमें यहां पे देखने को मिल रहा है
45 वाली आईपी। यह आईपी मुझे सबसे ज्यादा
देखने को मिल रही है। सो इसको हम इसको
देखते हैं 45 वाली। सो इट्स करेक्ट।
क्योंकि ये जो आईपी है ये सबसे ज्यादा
ब्लॉक लिस्ट में है। ये जो आईपी है 45
वाली तो इसको अब काउंट करके भी देख लेते
हैं। वैसे तो वी विल जस्ट काउंट इट
जस्ट गिव इट द नंबर हियर
एंड 297 टाइम्स। बट यहां पे ये ब्लॉक
लिस्ट में है रिकॉनसेंस के लिए। मतलब कि
इन द सेंस कि यहां पे कहने का मतलब है कि
सबसे ज्यादा रिकॉग्नेसेंस किसके तरफ से
हुई है। ठीक है? सबसे ज्यादा रिकॉनसेंस।
सो अब यहां पे रिकॉग्निसेंस का मतलब है कि
जब कोई नेटवर्क के ऊपर में कोई रिक्सेंस
हो रही है, किसी तरह का स्कैनिंग परफॉर्म
किया जा रहा है तो मोस्टली यहां पे माना
जाएगा कि वो नेटवर्क जो है वो उसका जो
फायर वाल है वो उस अटेम्प्ट को ब्लॉक कर
रही है, रोक रही है। तो हमने उसके लिए
सिंपल पहले ब्लॉक वाली जो लिस्ट है वो
निकाल ली। लाइक व्हाटएवर ब्लॉक लिस्ट इज़
देयर। अब इस ब्लॉक लिस्ट में हमारे पास
कुछ लिमिटेड आईपीस आई कि भैया कौन सी
आईपीस है? अब तो इसमें चारप आईपी जैसे 45
वाली एक आ गई हमारे पास 203 लिस्ट में
यहां पे 10 वाली है। उसके बाद यहां पे आप
नीचे की तरफ आप स्क्रॉल करेंगे तो 10 88
23 वाली यहां पे आईपी आ रही है। राइट? तो
और यहां पे इस तरीके से कुछ आईपीस आ रही
है। जिसमें से जो 45 वाली आईपी है ये सबसे
ज्यादा अ नंबर्स में है। राइट? सबसे
ज्यादा नंबर्स में है। तो नंबर्स यही आपसे
पूछा जा रहा है इस क्वेश्चन में कि कौन सी
एक्सटर्नल आईपी सबसे ज्यादा रिकॉग्निसेंस
करके दे रही है? तो हमारा ये सेम IPपी
एड्रेस वो 20345 वाली जो IP एड्रेस है वो
हो जाएगी। एंड इज़ द करेक्ट आंसर। ठीक है?
नाउ नेक्स्ट क्वेश्चन इन द फायरवल लॉग
व्हिच इंटरनल होस्ट वाज़ टारगेटेड बाय
स्कैट्स? फायर लॉग्स में ही हमारा ये फायर
लॉग्स ही है। राइट?
ठीक है?
वि इंटरनल होस्ट वास टारगेटेड बाय
स्कैन्स। कौन से इंटरनल होस्ट को टारगेट
किया गया स्कैन के लिए? तो आप देख सकते
हैं यहां पे ब्लॉक जो हो रही हैं ये जो
आईपी जो ब्लॉक हो रही हैं इसमें जो
टारगेटेड होस्ट आपको दिखेंगी। चलिए ऊपर की
तरफ बढ़ते हैं।
तो यहां पे एक आपका होस्ट है 10 ओ 50, एक
होस्ट है 10 ओo20। तो आप देख सकते हैं
यहां पे कि 50 पे एक पोर्ट पे 21 पे यहां
पे स्कैनिंग हुई है। 60 पे 23 पे हुई है।
50 पे 22 पे हुई है। राइट? 21 22 पे हुई
है। बट यहां पे एक और होस्ट है 20। इसके
44 44 4 पे 21 पे 21 पे अल अगेन 44 पे 23
पे 22 पे 22 पे 44 मतलब 20 वाला जो होस्ट
है इसके मल्टीपल पोर्ट्स पे मल्टीपल
टाइम्स जो है वो अटैक किया जा रहा है
ट्राई किया जा रहा है एंड दैट दैट्स व्हाई
वी कैन कंसीडर दिस एज आवर
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
IPपी एड्रेस या होस्ट एड्रेस जो कि स्कैन
के लिए टारगेट किया जा रहा है। तो इसको हम
चेक कर लेते हैं।
ये स्कैन के लिए मोस्टली टारगेट किया जा
रहा है। नाउ यहां पे अगेन नेक्स्ट
क्वेश्चन इज़ व्हिच यूजरनेम वाज़ टारगेटेड
इन वीpए लॉक्स? कौन सा यूजरनेम टारगेट
किया जा रहा है वीpए लॉक्स के अंदर? चलिए
वीpए लॉक्स एक बार चेक कर लेते हैं। राइट?
लेट्स चेक द वीपीए लॉक्स।
लेट्स चेक द वीpए लॉक्स। तो यहां पे मैं
कैट सॉरी कैट वीpए log करते हैं। कौन से
यूजरनेम को टारगेट किया जा रहा है? तो
यहां पे
देखते हैं कौन सा व्हिच यूजरनेम वाज़
टारगेटेड इन वीपीएलस तो आप देख सकते हैं
यहां पे कि कौन से यूजरनेम तो एक आपने
यहां पे देखा यहां पे हो रही है अ लाइक अ
सक्सेस असाइन
ये रिजल्ट्स आ रहे हैं सक्सेस असाइन राइट
सक्सेस असाइन सक्सेस फेल सक्सेस असाइन ये
सारे हैं बट यहां पे एक लॉग में आप इधर जब
देखेंगे यहां पे तो आपको दिख रहा होगा कि
एक यूजर है SBC बैकअप यह यूजर है SBC
अंडरs बैकअप ठीक है यह यूजर है इस पे जब
टारगेट किया जाए तो फेल फेल फेल फेल
टारगेट सब फेल हो रहे हैं सारे अटेम्प्ट्स
फेल हो रहे हैं बट एट द एंड ये लॉगिन
हो जा रहा है। सो इस यूजरनेम को टारगेट
किया जा रहा है मोस्टली एंड लॉग इन ली जा
रही है। तो मैं यहां पे इसको कॉपी कर ले
रहा हूं और एसबीसी बैकअप को यहां पेस्ट
करके चेक कर लेते हैं। इज़ द करेक्ट आंसर।
राइट? व्हाट इंटरनल IPपी वाज़ असाइन आफ्टर
सक्सेसफुल वीपीए लॉगिन? तो भाई सक्सेसफुल
वीपीए लॉग इन जब हुआ था तो कौन सा आईपी
एड्रेस असाइन हुआ है? तो ये वाला असाइन
हुआ है। देख लो यहां पे यही तो सक्सेसफुल
लॉग इन हुआ ना ये इस पे अटैक हो रहा था
एसबीसी बैकअप पे मल्टीपल अटै अटैक्स हुए।
सारे फेल हो रहे थे। एक सक्सेसफुल हुआ। तो
ये आईपी असाइन हो गई। 23 वाली सिंपल
क्या हुआ?
कॉपी नहीं हुई क्या? 10823
10 8023
लेट्स चेक करेक्ट
ठीक है गॉट इट अब यहां पे व्हिच पोर्ट वाज़
यूज़्ड फॉर लैटरल एसएमबी अटेमप्ट्स अब ये
एसएमबी अटेम्प्ट्स के लिए कौन सा पोर्ट
यूज़ किया अब एसएमबी के लिए भाई कौन सा हम
वीpए लॉक्स तो चेक करेंगे नहीं तो हम यहां
पे आइडियास अलर्ट्स लॉ्स को ओपन कर लेते
हैं यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं यहां पे
अलग-अलग लॉग यहां पे ये लॉक्स अब एसएमबी
के लिए तो अब यहां पे हम एसएमबी को सर्च
कर लेंगे। लेट्स ओपन द टर्मिनल। ओपन
टर्मिनल।
ठीक है? अब यहां पे कैट आईडीएस अलस देखते
हैं। गैब करते हैं एंड देखते हैं एसएमबी
से रिलेटेड कुछ है क्या? तो आप देख सकते
हैं यहां पे एसएमबी लेटरल मूवमेंट से
रिलेटेड यहां पे आपको मिल रहा है। अब इसके
लिए कौन सा पोर्ट जो है यहां पे आ रहा है
व्हिच पोर्ट वाज़ यू? तो एसएमबी के लिए
जनरली जो है 445 पोर्ट का यूज़ लिया जाता
है। तो आपको यहां पे दिख भी रहा होगा कि
यह जो पोर्ट है यह यूज़ हो रही है 44 45 तो
ऑब्वियस सी बात है इट्स 45
राइट सिंपल मिल गया हमें आंसर इन द
आईडियास लॉक्स। अब हम IDS लॉक्स पे चलते
हैं। ऑलरेडी आईडियास लॉक्स पे ही हैं।
गुड। व्हिच होस्ट बेक ऑन टू द C2? कौन सा
होस्ट C2 से बेक ऑन कर रहा है? तो भैया अब
यहां पे C2 सर्च कर लेंगे। सिंपल यहां पे
क्या करेंगे? सेम कमांड हुई गैप C2 कर
लेते हैं। कौन सा होस्ट भाई C2 के लिए बेक
ऑन कर रहा है? तो ऊपर की तरफ चलते हैं।
यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं पॉसिबल बिकॉनिंग
C2 ट्रोजन हॉर्स डिटेक्टेड। तो भैया ये
क्या दिखाना है? कौन से व्हिच होस्ट कौन
सा होस्ट ये बिकॉन कर रहा है? तो भैया
यहां पे हमारा होस्ट है 106 ये होस्ट है
भैया जो C2 के लिए बिकॉन कर रहा है तो
यहां पे होस्ट 60 चेक कर लेते हैं बिल्कुल
सही है 60 क्योंकि 60 होस्ट ही तो है जो
बिकॉन के लिए C2 बिकॉनिंग कर रहा है देखो
60 होस्ट 60 सब में 60 60 आपको दिख जाएगी
तो ये बिकॉन के लिए रिस्पांसिबल है तो दिस
इज़ द होस्ट उसके बाद है ड्यूरिंग द
इन्वेस्टिगेशन व्हिच आईपी वाज़ ऑब्ज़र्व टू
बी एसोसिएटेड विथ C2 कौन सा आईपी C2 से
एसोसिएटेड था इसमें हमें तो C2 पे कौन िंग
हो रही है भाई तो कौन सा आईपी एसोसिएटेड
था देख लेते हैं यहां पे C2 बेगिंग हो रही
है तो आई थिंक यह वाली आईपी है 198 5177
यही तो आईपी है जो इससे एसोसिएट एसोसिएटेड
है तो हम ये आईपी मेंशन कर देते हैं
करेक्ट क्योंकि इसी मतलब बिकॉन के लिए ये
होस्ट है और इस आईपी से एसोसिएटेड है ये
इस आईपी पे आपका जो है एक्सपिल्ट्रेशन या
जो भी हो रहा है कनेक्शन बन रही है सी टू
सर्वर से इस आईपी के इस आईपी को यूज़ में
लिया जा रहा है वहां पे तो ये आईपी इसका
आंसर हो जाएगी सिंपल सिंपल एज सिंपल व्हिच
होस्ट शोड द एक्स फिल्ट्रेशन अटेम्प्ट्स
कौन सा होस्ट एक्स फिल्ट्रेशन अटेम्प्ट शो
कर रहा है तो यहां पे सिंपल वही बात वही
चीज कर लेंगे एक्स फिल्ट्रेशन हो रही है
तो भैया हम एक्स फिल्ट्रेशन ग्रेब एक्स
फिल्ट्रेशन एक्स फिल्ट्रेशन देख लेते हैं
अच्छा ये आईडीएस वाली है आईडीएस में नहीं
आएगी एक्सिल्ट्रेशन फायर लॉग में आ जाएगा
एक्सिल्ट्रेशन अह सॉरी सॉरी अह आईडीएस में
एक बार ओपन कर लेते हैं। इसमें
एक्सफिल्ट्रेशन आपको देखने को मिलेगी।
लेट्स चेक द आईडीएस लॉग फॉर द एक्स
फिल्ट्रेशन।
ओके? तो यहां पर हम देखते हैं कैट आईडीएस
लॉग्स ग्रेप करते हैं। एक्स फिल्ट्रेशन
फिल्ट्रेशन स्पेलिंग सही होनी चाहिए गाइस
आपकी। नहीं तो फिर नहीं आएगा।
एक्सिल्ट्रेशन की स्पेलिंग गलत है क्या?
एक्स फिल्ट्रेशन
एक्सफिल्ट्रेशन सही तो है।
ई को कैपिटल करके देख लेते हैं एक बार।
हां, ई को कैपिटल कर दिया है। ठीक है? वो
E स्मॉल था तो नहीं आ रहा था। तो
एक्सफिल्ट्रेशन आ गई। यहां पे आ रहा है
व्हिच होस्ट शो द एक्सफिल्ट्रेशन एटम। कौन
सा होस्ट जो है एक्स फिल्ट्रेशन
अटेम्प्ट्स को शो कर रहा है। तो आप यहां
पे देख सकते हैं कि ये टाइम स्टैंप है
यहां पे आपका ईटी इनफो पॉसिबल एचटीडीटीपी
पोस्ट लार्ज अपलोड। यहां पे लार्ज अपलोड
हो रही है। क्लासिफिकेशन क्या है?
पोटेंशियल डेटा एक्सिल्ट्रेशन हो रही है।
प्रायोरिटी यहां पे टू दी गई है। कौन सी
होस्ट है? 1051
ये आपका एक्स फिल्ट्रेशन अटेमप्ट्स यहां
पे जो है हो रहा है। इस होस्ट के ऊपर ये
एक्सफिल्ट्रेशन अटेम्प्ट्स की जा रही है।
तो दिस इज़ द होस्ट दैट इज बीइंग
एक्सफिल्ट्रेटेड
और कहां पे जा रही है? इस C2 सर्वर के पास
आपकी जा रही है। तो यहां पे डालेंगे 190
क्या है भाई?
होस्ट तो होस्ट है यार। मैंने कॉपी कॉपी
नहीं हुआ क्या? 1051
10.0.51
चेक
डन हो गया हो गया सिंपल। दिस इज़ सॉल्वड।
सो इट वाज़ वेरी इजी लैब। आई थिंक कई लोगों
को ये लैब शायद कंफ्यूजिंग या शायद टफ लग
सकता होगा। पहले अगर आपने ट्राई करा होगा
या ट्राई करेंगे पहली बार तो। आपको लगेगा
कि ये टफ है। बट इट वाज़ वेरी इजी। अभी
आपने मेरे साथ-साथ करा या आपने देखा तो
आपको काफी अब इजी लगा होगा। आपको चीजें
समझ में आ गई होंगी कि लॉग्स को कैसे अभी
ये लॉग्स है मान लो आईडीएस की लॉग्स हैं।
इसमें सब कुछ पता चलता है कि क्लासिफिकेशन
क्या है? पोटेंशियल डेटा एक्सिल्ट्रेशन हो
रही है। प्रायोरिटी टू पे रखी गई है कि ये
प्रायोरिटी टू का है। हाई प्रायोरिटी है
थोड़ी और यहां पे आपको बताया जा रहा है
टीसीp पोर्ट टीसीp
प्रोटोकॉल का यूज़ हो रहा है। टीसीp
कनेक्शन है यहां पे। तो होस्ट कौन सा है
जिस पे एक्सिल्ट्रेशन हो रही है। तो ये
वाली है। किस पोर्ट पे हो रही है? 40000
पोर्ट पे हो रही है। और यह भेजी कहां जा
रही है भाई? डाटा कहां भेजा जा रहा है? तो
इस आईपी पे भेजा जा रहा है इस पोर्ट पे
8080 पोर्ट के थ्रू। तो ये आईपी किसकी हो
सकती है? C2 सर्वर की हो सकती है। अटैकर
कंट्रोल सर्वर हो सकता है जहां पे ये भेजा
जा रहा है। तो ये लॉग्स आपको पढ़ने आने
चाहिए। ये लॉग्स को पढ़ना बहुत आसान है।
इट्स वेरी वेरीरी इजी। एंड सेम चीजें जो
है आप बेसिकली लोकल होस्ट 8000 पोर्ट पे
जाके कर सकते हैं। जो कि इन्होंने यहां पे
बोला हुआ है कि अगर लोकल होस्ट 8000 पोर्ट
पे जाएंगे तो आपको यहां पे मिल जाएगी
स्प्लंक।
देखते हैं।
लेट्स ओपन द ब्राउज़र। लेट इट ओपन गाइस।
ग्रेट। अच्छा है। अच्छा है अगर आपको समझ
में आ गया तो।
तो यहां पर अब अगर हम जाते हैं। ओके ओके
ओके ओके यहां पर हम जाते हैं
लोकल होस्ट 8000 पे चलते हैं। तो स्प्लंक
की पैनल हमें मिलनी चाहिए स्प्लंक की।
देखो मिल गई स्प्लंक पैनल।
करेक्ट करेक्ट बिल्कुल सही निशा चौधरी।
मॉडरेट है सर। अच्छा मॉडरेट होगी शायद
राइट। [गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़] सो इस
प्लंक में हम लॉग इन हो रहे हैं। इस प्लंक
इज ओपनिंग फॉर अस।
सो इट्स
ओपन। लेट्स ओपन।
क्या है? इफ यू क्राई मतलब
यह कौन सी लैंग्वेज में लिखी है भाई? एक
तो इफ यू क्राई लिखा है उसके पहले क्या
लिखा है यार
ये कौन सी चाइनीस भाषा में है क्या यार
इफ यू क्राई के पहले क्या लिखा है भाई वो
बताओ वो सिंबल किस चीज के है मुझे नहीं
समझ में आ रहा सिंबल क्या है
तो यहां पे इस प्लंक पे आप यहां पे लाइक आ
चुके हैं यहां पे इस प्लंक पे एंड बेसिकली
अब सर्च वगैरह पे आके आप लाइक सर्च ये तो
सर्च हिस्ट्री है डैशबोर्ड पे यहां पे आप
डैशबोर्ड चूज़ कर सकते हैं लाइक यहां पे
सर्च सर्च एंड रिपोर्टिंग में जाके आप जो
चीजें हैं वो सर्च कर सकते हैं। लाइक
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
कुछ इस तरीके से
एंड यहां पे आप सर्च कर सकते हैं नेटवर्क
इंडेक्स इज इक्वल टू अ नेटवर्क लॉग्स।
नेटवर्क लॉग्स के लिए आप चेक कर सकते हैं
इसे। एंटर करेंगे तो आपको
मिल जाएगी शायद। अभी कुछ भी नहीं मिल रहा।
ऑल टाइम कर देते हैं। देखते हैं कुछ मिलता
है क्या या सो ऑल टाइम में हमें कुछ मिला
है यहां पे सोर्स टाइप में देखेंगे तो तीन
ऑल टाइम में मिला है हमें ऐसे नहीं मिला
24 घंटे से तो ऑल टाइम में देखेंगे तीन
सोर्स मिले हैं आपके फायर log ids log vpn
log आप देख सकते हैं firew log कितने हैं
1284 ids log 983 है वीpए log 28 है तो
यहां पे आपको spl सर्च प्रोसेसिंग जो एसएल
लैंग्वेज क्वरी जो होती है वो यूज़ करके
आपने नेटवर्क लॉक्स को यहां पे बेसिकली
निकाला है। सो उस टाइप में आपने नेटवर्क
लॉक्स देखे हैं। तीन लॉक्स आपको मिले हैं
जो वहां पे आपको देखने को मिल रहे थे। far
लॉक्स आईडीज़ लॉक्स फायर लॉक्स को ओपन
करेंगे तो आपको Far LX के अंदर की सारी
लॉक्स जो हैं वहां पे देखने को मिलेगी।
फिर आप इसमें अदर एसएल क्वरीज़ डाल के और
आप नॉर्मल आप इससे विजुअलाइज़ करके भी यहां
से भी आप लॉग्स वगैरह का वो सब काम कर
सकते हैं। सारी चीजें कर सकते हैं। ठीक
है? नॉट एन इशू।
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
ओके?
तो इस तरीके से आप स्प्लंक से कर सकते
हैं। अब स्प्लंक में कैसे क्वरी चलानी है,
क्या करना है, यह सारी चीजें मैंने ऑलरेडी
स्प्ल वाली वीडियो में बताई हुई है। अगर
आपको नहीं पता, आपने अभी तक नहीं देखी है,
आई रिक्वेस्ट यू टू वॉच द स्प्लक वाली
वीडियो आल्सो। डिफ़्रॉनिक्स एकडमी पे चले
जाइएगा। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] लाइव
पे चले जाइएगा। यहां पे नीचे की तरफ
स्क्रॉल करेंगे। नीचे की तरफ स्क्रॉल
करेंगे तो यहां पे आपको जो क्लास देखने को
मिलेगी 1 1/2 घंटे की लगभग गाइड टू
स्प्लंक फॉर एसओसी। इसमें पूरी स्प्रंग के
बारे में मैंने आपको सिखाया है, बताया है।
सो आपको मजा आएगा। बस दैट्स इट। सो दैट्स
इट फॉर टुडेेस सेशन गाइस। इट वाज़ अमेजिंग।
आई वुड रिक्वेस्ट एवरीबॉडी टू प्लीज
कंप्लीट द ट्राईकमी लैब। इसको आप कंप्लीट
कर लीजिएगा इस सेक्शन को। मैं यहां पे
इसको टर्मिनेट कर देता हूं मशीन को फिलहाल
के लिए। इट्स नॉट रिक्वायर्ड एनीमोर।
ठीक है? इसको कर लीजिएगा।
इट्स वेरीेंट। दैट्स इट। तो आज का सेशन
यहां पे हम
जस्ट अ सेकंड गाइस।
तो आज का सेशन हम यहीं पे कंप्लीट करते
हैं। एंड करते हैं। एंड लेट्स मूव टू द
चैट सेक्शन।
एक बार चैट सेक्शन पे मैं आ जाता हूं
जल्दी से। ट
आ गए हम चैट सेक्शन पे। इट वास फन। थैंक
यू वेरी मच।
नेक्स्ट क्लास जल्दी आएगी भाई डोंट वरी
ओके सो
योर वेलकम गाइस वेलकम वेलकम एंड नेक्स्ट
क्लास भी हम लेकर आएंगे जल्दी ही अब
ज्यादा क्लासेस नहीं बची है इस क्लास में
इस सीरीज में सॉरी नॉट मच ऑफ द क्लासेस आर
लेफ्ट सो मजा आएगा आपको अब हम एंड की तरफ
बढ़ेंगे जब हम एंड करेंगे इस सीरीज को तो
सर एल1 जॉब इज ओवर एआई टेकिंग ओवर ये सब
मत करो ये सब मत सोचो यार बहुत लोग तो
बहुत लोगों की जॉब इसलिए चली गई है
क्योंकि वो यह सोचने लगे कि एआई मेरा जॉब
ले लेगा। सोचते-सचते उनकी जॉब चली गई। ऐसा
हुआ है बहुत लोगों के साथ। मैंने देखा है
कॉर्पोरेट में। बहुत लोग इस टेंशन में जॉब
गवा चुके हैं। उनके दिमाग में टेंशन अरे
यार अब तो एआई आ चुका है। अब हमारा काम
कैसे होगा? हमारा काम एआई करेगा। हमारी तो
जॉब चली जाएगी। और ऐसे टेंशन में वो अपने
काम कर नहीं पा रहे हैं। टेंशन के मारे और
उनको निकाल दिया कंपनी से। ऐसा भी हुआ है।
तो भाई ऐसे सोचो मत। स्किल्स गेन करो।
ह्यूमन स्किल्स, ह्यूमन लॉजिक, ह्यूमन
चीजों का कोई तोड़ नहीं है। फिलहाल तो जब
तक जब तक एजीआई वगैरह का सीन नहीं बनता
है, एजीआई वगैरह की चीजें नहीं आती है तब
तक कुछ नहीं है। आप मस्ती से रहो। अभी यार
देखो यार अभी यह बस एक रोबोट है जिसको आप
यूज़ कर रहे हो। राइट? इट्स जस्ट अ रोबोट।
यह आयरन मैन का
रोबोट [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] है।
अल्ट्रॉन जब अगर आ जाए ना तब दिक्कत है।
अल्ट्रॉन बनेगी। कि अल्ट्रॉन जब
एग्जीक्यूट होगी अल्ट्रॉन जब आएगा तब
टेंशन की बात है यार अभी अल्ट्रॉन आया
नहीं है यार अभी टाइम है अल्ट्रॉन को आने
में भाई तो टेंशन मत रहो मस्तीमस्ती में
स्किल्स गेन करो ठीक है और एi को भी सीखो
एआई के भी नॉलेज लो
चलिए यहां पे जो स्पैम कर रहे हैं उनको
थोड़ा सा वो कर देते हैं।
स्पैम करते हैं इसलिए किया है।
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
नॉट एन इशू कोई बात नहीं सीरीज आती है
जाती हैं। अच्छा मैं आप सब से एक सजेशन
लेना चाहता हूं। आई वांट टू टेक अ सजेशन
फ्रॉम यू गाइस। आप में से सभी लोग बताइए
वि फ्री सीरीज यू वांट टू
वांट यू वांट अस टू ब्रिंग ऑन दिस
डेफ्रोनिक्स एकडमी YouTube चैनल जो इसके
बाद आनी चाहिए। आपको क्या लगता है? कोई
सेंसिबल
सीरीज बताइएगा प्लीज कुछ भी मत बोलिएगा
प्लीज इट्स अ रिक्वेस्ट ऐसा नहीं कि कुछ
भी बोल दीजिएगा कुछ सेंसिबल जो रियल में
जिसकी रिक्वायरमेंट हो नीड हो ऐसा कुछ
बताइए आप में से
एल2 एसओसी एल2 एल3 की ट्रेनिंग फ्री नहीं
आएगी एसओसी एसओसी एल2 और l3 की हम पेड
ट्रेनिंग लेकर आएंगे। बहुत जल्द उसकी यह
अनाउंसमेंट आपको मिल जाएगी। दैट विल बी
कंप्लीटली पेड। तो मैं सीधा-सीधा डायरेक्ट
बोलता हूं। मैं कोई यह ऐसा नहीं कि हां
आपको खुश करने के लिए मैं बोल दूंगा कि
हां अजय कि कुछ नहीं है। किसी को खुश नहीं
करना। कुछ नहीं करना। जो चीजें फ्री हैं,
फ्री हैं। जो चीजें पेड है पेड है। L2 L3
की पेड ट्रेनिंग आएगी। उसके अलावा बताइए।
जस्ट लेट मी नो। अदर दैन दैट।
रेड टीमिंग की यार ऑलरेडी फ्री कितनी
क्लासेस हो चुकी हैं भाई? वह रेड टीमिंग
की ही तो है। डीएई आपका रेड टीमिंग की ही
क्लासेस हैं। डीईए की क्लासेस के बारे में
शायद आपको अभी उतना नहीं पता है। डीईए
डीईएई जो हमारी सीरीज है आप में से कई लोग
उसको तो फॉलो नहीं करते हैं शायद। बट
कीजिए जरूर। इट्स अ रिक्वेस्ट टू यू। लाइव
सेक्शन में आप या प्लेलिस्ट में आप आइएगा।
तो आपको यहां पे एक प्लेलिस्ट मिलेगी डीएई
डिफ्रॉनिक्स एथिकल हैकर एसेंशियल्स ये
एसेंशियल्स लिखा है बट इसमें बहुत कुछ है
भाई ये ट्रेनिंग को फॉलो करो मतलब दिमाग
खराब हो जाएगा इस ट्रेनिंग को फॉलो करके
आपका यह ऑलरेडी एक रेड टीमिंग कोर्स है
रेड इट फ्री में आपको सिखाई जा रही है 75
क्लासेस हो चुकी हैं ऑलरेडी और क्लासेस हो
भी रही हैं जस्ट फॉलो इट फॉलो इट गाइस
प्लीज डीईएचई को फॉलो करो
डिजिटल फॉरेंसिक्स का बेसिक्स ठीक है।
Linux एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर नॉट मच ऑफ़ पीपल आर
इंटरेस्टेड इन Linux एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर। सो
वी विल नॉट ब्रिंग दैट।
आई एम न्यू। आई लाइक योर टीचिंग। थैंक यू
वेरी मच। फॉरेन सिक्स आई थिंक। ओके।
हम्म।
आई एम ओके
क्लाउड सिक्योरिटी Android सिक्योरिटी ओके
कोर्स फॉर Microsoft सेंटिनल ओके क्लाउड
सिक्योरिटी फॉर अच्छा मतलब ज्यादातर वोट्स
फॉरेंसिक्स के आ रहे हैं। डिजिटल
फॉरेंसिक्स के एंड क्लाउड सिक्योरिटी के आ
रहे हैं। राइट? तो ये दो टॉपिक को मैं मेन
मेनली मान लूं कि ज्यादातर लोगों की
डिमांड है क्लाउड सिक्योरिटी एंड डिजिटल
फॉरेंसिक। सबसे ज्यादा लोग इसी को वोट कर
रहे हैं। राइट? ये दो टॉपिक्स को यही है
ना?
आई थिंक यही है। राइट?
चलिए मैं एक मैं एक पोल करा लेता हूं छोटा
सा आप लोग इसका आंसर कीजिएगा। ठीक है? अ
वि टॉपिक
क्लाउड सिक्योरिटी
डिजिटल फॉरेंसिक्स मैंने आपको एक पोल दिया
हुआ है। उसमें आप लोग वोट कीजिए जरा।
लेट्स सी हाउ मेनी ऑफ यू आर वोटिंग इन वि
टॉपिक फेवर।
सो एक बार वोट कर दीजिए सभी लोग जितने भी
लोग यहां पे देख रहे हैं अभी दोनों
टॉपिक्स के लिए मैंने वोटिंग का आपको दिया
हुआ है। तो आप एक बार वोट कीजिए। जितने भी
लोग यहां पे प्रेजेंट हैं एटलीस्ट वोट
एवरीबॉडी। तभी मुझे एग्जैक्ट आईडिया
लगेगा। आप लोगों में से अगर कम कम करेंगे
वोट ज्यादा सभी लोग नहीं करेंगे तो आईडिया
नहीं लग पाएगा। सो प्लीज एवरीबडी वोट।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
चलिए 1 मिनट का समय है। आप वोट कीजिए।
उसके बाद पोल को मैं एंड कर दूंगा। एंड
देन आपको बताऊंगा रिजल्ट। एग्जैक्ट रिजल्ट
बताऊंगा मैं फिर आपको।
सो प्लीज वोट गाइस। प्लीज वोट। प्लीज वोट।
जल्दी वोट कीजिए गाइस। फटाफट।
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
जल्दी नहीं कोई एक ही टॉपिक आएगी। वोट
कीजिए जल्दी। फटाफट।
व्हाट [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] विल बी
आस्क्ड इन द इंटरव्यू अपार्ट फ्रॉम कोर?
जो भी आपसे आपसे जो भी पूछा जाएगा वो मैं
आपको बताऊंगा। टेंशन नहीं लेनी है आपको।
तो यहां पर वोटिंग ऑलमोस्ट हो चुकी है
कंप्लीट। लगभग
35 वोट्स आ चुके हैं जितने प्रेजेंट है
लाइव में। सो मैं यहां पर पोल को एंड कर
रहा हूं। एंड यहां पर रिजल्ट जो है आपके
सामने है। अ रिजल्ट इज क्लाउड सिक्योरिटी
को सबसे ज्यादा वोट मिले हैं। 56% देन
डिजिटल फॉरेंसिक्स को 44%। सो होपफुली
क्लाउड सिक्योरिटी का हम एक बेसिक कोर्स
शायद लेकर आए आपके लिए। अभी मैं कंफर्म
नहीं बोल रहा बट मे बी वी कैन ब्रिंग अ
फ्री क्लाउड सिक्योरिटी कोर्स। अब इसको वन
शॉट में रखना है मतलब एक शॉट में बनाएं
लाइक अराउंड 7 आठ घंटे की 10 घंटे की या
ऐसी ही जैसी एसओसी की चल रही थी वैसे ही
लाएं आप बताइए वन शॉट
7 8 10 घंटे की एक बार में या फिर सीरीज
ऐसी क्लासेस वाइज जैसे कि आपकी अभी हमारी
एसओसी की चल रही है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ओके
चुप हो जा राडार Intel शांति चुप हो जा
बच्चे [अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
वन शॉट वन शॉट वन शॉट सीरीज वन शॉट वन शॉट
काफी लोग एसओसी के लिए भी बोल रहे हैं।
काफी लोग सीरीज के लिए भी बोल रहे हैं।
चलो वह हम डिसाइड कर लेंगे। चलो लेट्स
लेट्स सी व्हाट इज़ हैपनिंग। दैट वी विल वी
विल डिसाइड राइट। लाइव क्लास करनी है कि
सीरीज करनी है। क्या करना है कि वन शॉट
लाना है कि क्या करना है वो हम डिसाइड कर
लेंगे। ठीक है?
मैं सीरीज के मैं भी सीरीज के फेवर में
हूं। जैसे अभी एसओसी की चल रही है। वैसे
ही सेम सीरीज के फेवर में हूं। मुझे भी
ज्यादा यह पसंद है क्योंकि इससे आपका लाइव
इंटरेक्शन होता है। एक अलग थोड़ी सी चीज
होती है तो वह मजा भी आता है थोड़ा और
आपको टाइम भी मिलता है। गैप भी मिलता है
जब कुछ क्लासेस आती है तो उनको प्रिपेयर
करने का भी गैप मिलता है। तो थोड़ा सही
होता है। बाकी देख लेते हैं।
और आप सभी लोग वो एथिकल हैकिंग की क्लास
जो वन शॉट आई है 5 1:30 घंटे की उसको जरूर
देखिएगा। एज एन एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट एलोवन
आपका बेसिक एथिकल हैकिंग का कंप्लीट हो
जाएगा। प्लीज उसको जरूर देखिएगा। इट्स अ
रिक्वेस्ट और शेयर कर दीजिएगा। 3 लाख
व्यूज तक पहुंचाना है उसको कैसे भी करके।
ओके। नो एक्स
ओ1 श्योर
या
एसओसी की जल्दी ही एक के क्रिएशन एसओसी की
जल्दी ही कंप्लीट होने वाली है। बेफिक्र
रहिए। जो भी यहां से जाएंगे लाइक ठोकते
हुए जाना भाई।
85 लाइक्स हैं। 100 लाइक्स पर पहुंचा देना
सभी लोग।
रडार Intel हां जी सब लीगल है भाई। हम खुद
ही लीगल हैं। हम जो भी करते हैं वो सब
लीगल ही होता और लीगल ना भी हो तो लीगल हो
जाता है। हम करते हैं तो रडार Intel भाई
एवरीथिंग इज लीगल।
दिक्कत है तो बताओ।
यू आर अ गुड टीचर। आई प्रेफर यू। थैंक यू
वेरी मच।
थैंक यू वेरी मच।
हम [हंसी]
हाइप ऑप्शन जो है मोबाइल पे जब आप वीडियो
देखेंगे ना तो वहां पे कमेंट्स के पास
जाएंगे तो वहां पे इसे स्लाइड करेंगे तो
हाइप का ऑप्शन आता है।
सर पोकी मतलब क्यूट। ओके थैंक यू वेरी मच।
थैंक यू वेरी मच
सर। इस मंथ कंप्लीट हां इस मंथ में आपका
आपका मोस्ट प्रोबेब्ली जो है ये कंप्लीट
हो जाएगा जो एसओसी सीरीज है।
सर माय मूड गेट्स रिफ्रेश आफ्टर रीडिंग।
थैंक यू वेरी मच। थैंक यू। थैंक यू वेरी
मच।
चलिए टॉप फेंस की लिस्ट देख लेते हैं। यह
हमारे टॉप फेंस की लिस्ट है। एंड इट्स
ग्रेट। यह टॉफेंस की हमारी लिस्ट है। आप
देख सकते हैं। यह लोग काफी लॉन्ग ड्यूरेशन
के लिए जुड़े रहते हैं हमसे एंड कंटीन्यूस
इंटरेक्ट करते हैं। सो दैट्स ग्रेट सीइंग
देम एंड कई ऐसे नाम है जो बहुत शुरू से
मैं देख रहा हूं इनमें। एंड दैट्स द ग्रेट
स्पिरिट आई थिंक जो यू हैव। सो दैट्स
ग्रेट। बढ़िया है।
हाउ इट्स लीगल? कैन यू प्लीज टेल? आई एम
नॉट हियर टू टेल यू एनीथिंग। थैंक यू वेरी
मच। उसकी कोई जरूरत नहीं है भाई।
नो यू आर अ नॉर्मल यूजर एंड इफ यू आर
यूजिंग दैट्स नॉट बी लीगल। दैट्स दैट्स
विल दैट विल बी सॉरी लीगल। और आप नॉर्मल
यूजर की तरह यूज़ करें। एलए की तरह यूज़
करें तो भी लीगल है। कैसे भी करो आप लीगल
है। टेंशन फ्री रहो।
चलिए ओके गाइस देन थैंक यू वेरी मच। आज की
क्लास यहीं पे हम एंड करते हैं। एंड मजा
आया क्लास में। नेक्स्ट क्लास में बहुत
जल्द मिलते हैं। एंड जो भी रिमेनिंग
टॉपिक्स है उसको कंप्लीट करते हैं।
एसोसिएशन से इसको एंड करते हैं। फिर हम
इंटरव्यूज के लिए बात करेंगे। इंटरव्यूज
के लिए आपके लिए अप्लाई वगैरह करवाएंगे
आपसे। देखते हैं फिर आप में से कितने
लोगों की जॉब लगती है, क्या होता है। वी
विल सी राइट। सो थैंक यू वेरी मच फॉर
जॉइनिंग द सेशन गाइस। जाते-जाते लाइक ठोक
दो एक बार लाइक ठोक के 100
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] लाइक्स करके
जाना। एंड मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट क्लास में।
इस वीडियो को शेयर कर दीजिएगा अपने
दोस्तों के बीच, अपने एसओसी एंथोजियास्टिक
लोगों के बीच जिनको एसओसी के बारे में
पढ़ना है। प्लीज गो एंड शेयर द वीडियो एंड
मोबाइल पे देख रहे हैं तो वीडियो को हाइप
जरूर कर दीजिएगा। कमेंट सेक्शन के पास
स्लाइड कीजिएगा। हाइप का ऑप्शन आएगा। थैंक
यू वेरी मच। टाटा बाय-ब।